laser is a single page application
framework created by microsoft with
blader you write c sharp to generate
dynamic content
and with blader you can become a full
stack developer with c sharp on both
front end and back end my name is frank
liu i'll be talking about the
architecture and how it works for the
first three modules
then we'll get into every aspect of
laser in-depth towards the end we will
be creating a reusable data grid
component using the knowledge that we
are going to learn without further ado
let's get started
blazer is for web development
so to talk about laser architecture i
want to talk about two typical web
development architecture first the first
one is the
very typical request and response model
where you have a
browser
and you have your user interact with the
browser and whenever the user wants to
see something
the browser
sends
a
http
request
to the server side server
and the server
process the request
here and
returns
a rest http
response
and what's in the http response is html
and then the http
the html will be rendered on the screen
and the user sees it and the user is
happy
so this is the first
architecture
and
a lot of the development technology
actually uses this for example the
original
from microsoft's original classic asp
right so asb
and then you have jsp
and then you have
the microsoft asp.net web forms
you have
asp.net mvc
and
the asp.net core mvc
yeah a lot of them are using this
architecture
with some help wizard without some help
of javascript
and the second architecture is
it's more interactive
that's when the um
the web development world notice that
that this first architecture
it's good
but
the performance wise it's it's not great
and
when the development world notice that
the
the browser actually
it runs it's its desktop application it
runs on the computer
and has its own powerful
um compute computing power
and
as the
client computer is getting more and more
powerful
the smartphone also gets very very
powerful
the browser has a
very powerful computing power
the storage is getting bigger and bigger
as well
so then
why don't we
take advantage of this
computing power
so that
introduced the second
architecture
where we actually
use this
javascript
running directly on the browser
and renders
the result to the dome
right and here
let's start from the user side so the
user interacts with
the browser
and then um
the browser
the dom actually uh
sends events
like the user clicks on button
so you have a on click event
right and then
some other controls may trigger on
change event
so on key down on key up those kind of
events are handled in the javascript
and then the javascript
since
calls the web api running on the server
nowadays you have more options but uh
let's just use web api
for uh for example
right
so
it sends a
web api
so this is a http request
and then the web api
actually uh
communicates
typically communicates with a database
to get the data
so here in this example i was just uh
i didn't talk about the
details here
but in the second architecture i have to
so javascript calls the http uh
the the web api or just let's call it
the rest api
and then
it returns a
http
response
typically in the format of
json
and then
the data
is
consumed here in the javascript
right that is consumed here in the
javascript
and html is created
or updated
and sends
to the renders to the dome
the user sees it
so that
leads stood blazer
so um we have javascript frameworks the
friend and frameworks um so we have uh
jquery
so jquery is probably a library so we
have front-end frameworks and front-end
libraries like jquery
react
angular vue.js
all of these
right so we're asking
a question that i react is from facebook
and uh angular is from google
so then where is microsoft
everybody's uh kind of expecting that
um
but
just recently
we have been waiting for a long time
just recently
microsoft came
with
a new technology that's called blazer
and
the blader architecture is actually
other two actually two kinds of
architecture from blazer
one is the client side one is the server
side
and the client side is actually very
very similar
to
the second type of architecture
so if i can copy this
i can copy this
so
laser is very very similar to the first
architecture so the only thing that is
different here is instead of using
javascript we're having c-sharp here it
means that we can use c-sharp on the
server-side as well as on the client
side that opens a lot of doors for us
javascript is nice it's good
but then it's actually evolves in a very
dangerous speed
so let's also talk about the server side
so blazer
has a hosting model
that is
blindside as well server side
and let's start with the on the browser
so we also have the stone here
and instead of having the c sharp code
basically the
service hosting model we pull the c
sharp code from the client side
to the server side
okay so here instead of c sharp we're
having
blazer
it's a javascript file i forgot the name
but
once we go to the computer i'm going to
show you where the file is
so we're having the c trap library
pulled over
to
the
server side and that's why they call it
hosting model so we have the laser the
blazer applications can call the service
layer and then the service layer can
call the repository layer and the
repository can work with contacts db
contacts if we are using
entity framework
but how the server side communicate with
the client side that's
where we have the websocket
wrapped around by signing our right so
this is dedicated communication channel
it means that we are using
instead of http request response we're
sending messages back and forth
and um
so this channel is maintained constantly
and that's uh this very smart way
and this blazer dot js this this this
file is used to communicate
with the
um
laser application this rc short code
there and the performance is also pretty
amazing and this uh
so the architecture that
we're comparing the architecture between
laser client-side and blazer server-side
is that
if we are
with this client-side application
actually um
we can
create microservices
uh by creating different web apis or
yeah
and
but server side we can also do that um
if we do that then the we cannot call
the service layer and posture layer or
to context to be contacts directly in
the same machine
because this is monolithic so we if
we're trying to do the monolithic
architecture on the server side then we
cannot
um
uh
yeah it's not gonna
be very efficient
and if we want to still support
microservices then we have to pull the
service layer and postulator outside to
a different machine to different hosting
environment
the request response
architecture is stateless
the second
the front-end frameworks um
architecture we maintaining state on the
client side
but this part is also stateless right
the communication part with the backend
api
and
with the laser client side we're
maintaining the state also in the client
side
um
and with the server
see the problem is that we're
maintaining the state on the server so
if we are having
we're having a lot of users on the
client side
that means we're going to host a lot of
state
and that really
we're going to host the state on the
server side for you know many many times
and that's really costing a lot of
resources
and that's going to be a
issue that we need to consider
whether or not we are having the service
layer hosted somewhere else as apis
this is something we need to consider
uh in in the next video i'm going to
take a deeper look at the
architecture the blazer architecture
to explain why we can
host c-sharp
directly in the browser how microsoft
does this
and then
how it actually works
let's take a deeper look at the blazer
architecture have a browser here
and again
i'll draw the dome here
and
we need to be able to
run the code on the browser
and how do we do that there is this
thing
that's called webassembly
and if you go to the web apps assembly
the website
they say that web assembly is a compiler
target
so then what is
a compiler target
we have a compiler here
there's this compiler source
and then
there's this compiler target
so compiler source
is the source language
and compiler target
is just the
target language
so compiler is basically when it
compiles convert the stress language to
the target language so for example
c-sharp
after compilation
it turns into
right it turns into intermediate
language
and
how does an intermediate language runs
on us on a computer
so if we have a computer here
the immediate language is not a
machine language that can run directly
on this on the computer
so what it does is that
it has we have a
net
runtime
right and the intermediate language
actually
runs within the context of dynamic
runtime
so if we come back
to this later topic
so websimply
is
a let's say it's a language
that can run directly in the browser
and how can that be possible
that's because
most of the
vendors like chrome
google chrome
microsoft edge
internet explorer
firefox most of the vendors
they agreed on this web assembly
standard
and
most of them most of the products
they are able to support
this
web apps only standard so as long as
your code is written in this web
assembly language
then
there's
browser supported and there is actually
a kind of like natively dress really
fast
performance is amazing so
how can the c sharp run
inside the browser
the answer is it runs as a web assembly
that's not entirely true
in terms of
how blazer runs on the browser blazer
actually
does not we do not actually turn
the c-sharp codes into web assembly
what it does is that there is this thing
that is called mono
web assembly and the mono web assembly
is a runtime
mono web assembly itself
is
a
web web assembly
so it runs on the browser so if i draw
if i draw another
square here
and if we call this
mono
web
assembly
so this is the um
when the server runs
so if we have server here
and if we have our uh
blazer application hosted
in the
server
and
when the user sends a http request
through the browser
the server actually first it pushes
the
mono
web assembly to the browser
all right and
it it is actually a run time
it works like a runtime so after that
our
blazer applications the blazer framework
as well as dotnet standard
libraries
all of the dependencies of our
blazer applications will be downloaded
to the server
so
the next layer would be
would be our um
done at runtime so
oh sorry not the
the dyna standard done standard
and the next layer
so this
would be also downloaded and
all right so we have our
blazer framework here
and within the blazer framework
our blazer application actually runs
here
so lastly
our replacer app runs here
and
how does the blazer app actually
produces the
html
as we know that
blazer actually uses a
component-based
architecture which means
our developers actually created a lot of
components
we create components
inside the blazer applications
so and we call it the component tree so
for example if we have
a computer if we have a
ui design that looks like
this so we have a menu items and then we
have
we have uh some area
that looks like that
and within this area
we have uh
two like kind of like two panels
and
something is displayed here and then
some things will play here and then
a picture
maybe
displayed here
then
here we actually have
a
component tree here right so we have our
root component which is this one right
the biggest one so we have a root
component and then we have
two components on the second level
and then we
have in here we have
three components
right so it's component tree
so this component tree
constantly changes when user interacts
with the use with the interface
right
so the user clicks somewhere or press
keys changes the data so the data would
be changing the components would be
reloading
right sometimes it may switch to a
completely different
set of components
so this component tree is actually being
tracked by the blazer application
so we would have two
so this is the previous component three
the previous tree
and
this is the current tree
currently
so
whenever user makes some changes
it generates the current tree
and then it compares with the previous
tree
right so here it makes a comparison
between this two
uh the previous tree and the current
tree and then it creates a div
it calculates a
component tree div
and this component tree def
will be sent
to the dome and used to update the dom
and then the user would be able to see
the changes
so
this is the the client side blazer
right
this is how it works
so to summarize a little bit
the blazer application
they are actually so all of these are c
sharp
dlls right c sharp d allows
c sharp dll
and um
and this is mono
uh webassembly this is actually a web
assembly
so this is the client side
so the server set
let's cover server side here the server
side blazer
works very similarly just like
in our previous video
we covered
but
all these things actually happens on the
server side that's why it's called
server side so
if i try to cover that again here
so we have a browser here
right and then we have our dom here
and in here
we have the
blazer
now i remember the name
blades are server
dot js
and then on the server i have to draw a
bigger
rectangle here to represent the server
so in here
of course we're going to have our
dotnet
if i follow the same way of drawing
we're going to have our
dotnet framework
so we're not limited
we can use the fold on our framework
here it doesn't have to be using
that.net standard
we can have our.net framework
and then within that you can run our
blazer
please a framework
and within it we have our laser app
and then we have our
previous tree and current tree
and uh
so our bridger
applications also
communicates where's the where
uh through the signal error channel
right
signal our
websocket channel
so
then what happens is that the um the
user sends requests
and then
the message is sent over to the blazer
application
and the components gets updated the data
gets refreshed
and
the comparison happens here
and then this christie
ui
dev
all right so this ui div
is sent over
to the
browser through the blader server dot js
file
and then
gets
the actual
dom is updated
that the user sees the results
so that's how blazer
works in detail
when it comes to the pros obviously pros
with the web assembly model is that you
fully utilize the client-side resources
and all flows the burden of the server
right because everything
that is needed is already on the
client-side
browser but the cause of the
webassembly hosting model is that
because
it
it downloads everything so the initial
load is low
and that's
those are the main pros and cons of
webassembly everything else is pretty
minor so i'm not going to mention
for the server side
the server side
there's also pros and cons
and obviously
the pros
of one hosting model is going to be the
cost of of the other one
and the cost of the
one wholesome model will be the pros
with the other model right so for the
pros of the blazer server
the the first one is you have a very
fast initial load because everything is
actually
within the server side and
there's there's not much
that you you need to uh to be sent to
the server right the only thing is this
ui difference and it's
it's it's very minimum because it's only
the difference between the two
uh
the previous
render tree and the current render tree
plus this ui difference is in a battery
format all right so it's very compact
so you you have a fast initial load
that's obvious for the first server
setup laser
and also
for developers
because everything is hosted on the
server side
so we can directly call the service
layers repository layers without going
through
apis for example rest api right
so
all of the concerns related to calling
rest apis
are
you don't have to consider it
if you choose to not incorporating the
rest apis right so for example
you don't have to worry about security
concerns you don't have to worry about
the api
mapping from the json results to objects
and all of those things right so you
have a much faster development speed so
it's good for prototyping so um but what
what are the columns of the the server
side hosting model because everything is
hosted on the server side
let's say you're going to have a
variable that stores
thousands of hundreds of rows of data
and that data has to be rendered
to
the render tree and you have two render
trees and because you have you already
in the variable you already have
thousands of
rows
okay
and then those rows has to be reflected
within those two render trees one is for
the previous previous version one is for
the current version
so you actually
keep a large amount of data on the
server side and that's just
for for one user and if you have many
users imagine you have used a large
amount of memory for for just one user
session and you have many users like
this right
you have like
1 000 users
so
you gotta do like a thousand times
uh
three because you have basically
three copies of that data one is in the
variable one is in the previous render
tree and one is in the current render
tree and then that amount
of memory you use for each
for that variable right and if you you
have
10 000 records
in that variable 10 000 rows and each
row
takes
a lot of a lot of a large amount of data
then
this is going to be huge amount of data
for for all of the users to use and all
of that comes from just one server right
your server side this one
whereas if you use a client-side hosting
model
then
all of this
well you're not gonna first of all
you're not gonna have this 1000
right you're gonna have three copies
you're gonna have a variable but but
this is gonna be on the client side it's
gonna be within the browser
so as long as you have a very good
client
a slide is not a very thin client
then it is going to work
but whereas if you do this on the server
side it's not going to work
so
so let's let's list out the pros and
cons for each so for the
for the client side we have uh
what is the pros
for the web assembly right so fully
utilize
the
power
of the
client
right
and uh
what are the cons
so the cost is
slow
initial load
because there are so many files to load
like this this part so many files
uh and then
this is
this is the web assembly right and the
server side
the pros
fast
first
initial
load and then we have
fast
development
right and what are the cost
the burden
on the server
and
last one i forgot to cover is
because of the signal
r channel here what if the
channel the signal
signal r
gets
disconnected
right
so
i think i personally think that if you
want to create a small application
then the server side is a very good
choice
and
and
you also
need to be
if you were to use the server side
blazer to create a
midsize or big size application you
really need to pay attention to
to how you load the data do not load
large amount of data always
always load the data that you want to
display and then use paging or something
like that to to get the next
screen of data
to
to the browser
do not load
everything that will really slow down
the process
uh
and uh for the problem problem with the
signal arterial disconnection
just always make sure that you save
your data often
and
so when there is a disconnection
and you have to do a screen refresh
to to reconnect the signal or channel
then
then you only lose
the limited amount of data
all right so overall i do think that a
better choice is to use the web assembly
hosting model
instead of the server-side hosting model
but
um
but with very careful design
you do
you can use the server-side model
for
for a large project
i want to talk about the project
structure of both the web assembly
blazer as well as the blazer server side
so
first i want to create a project
and it's going to be
blazer
and
i'll call this blob blazer
web
assembly
and i'll choose the
web assembly template
all right that's pretty simple
and uh let's run this right away before
so before we go into the uh
project structure i wanted to
show you guys something else
for both the wipe assembly blazer as
well as the server side blazer so
if i run it
let's see it's loading and then we can
see the the pages
the user interface
so what i wanted to show you guys is if
i use the developer tool
and i go to network tab
i have to do a refresh
you can see all these things are being
downloaded
you see the loading
it takes a long time
and then all these are downloaded so
let's take a look at what are actually
downloaded
so at the beginning
we have this blader webassembly.js file
that is downloaded
and then this file initializes the
download of the other things
this is the mono web assembly which is
the
the only web assembly this is the uh the
context so all of the other ones run
within this context
as i've covered in the second video
so we can see that we have the blazer
framework and we have
the
net
assemblies
all the dependencies we have uh also our
uh
application as well
so this because i call it blazer
webassembly this is the project
this is the project so this is our
application dll and
our debug information is also
downloaded here
so that's what i wanted to show you on
the
client-side
map assembly blazer
so if i stop this for now
okay let's open another video studio
instance and create another
project which is the blazer server side
it's the same process
but this time i call it laser server
side
okay
and
i choose the server
side app
all right so
again before i go into the structure
i want to run the app
all right
same drill
we're going to
look at the
developer tool
uh we'll clear it
refresh
and this time let's take a look at
what's our downloaded
so
we only have this js file that is
downloaded
and then we have this
and then we have this uh
the websocket which is the signalguard
signalr channel
so we can see that
we clear this
so each time
if i do anything
clear again click on this
see
each time i do anything with the
components the channel there is it's
being used to pass message back and
forth because all of our components and
the state of the components
are actually being
capped on the server side and we're
using the signalr channel to send back
and forth the message and
yeah that's
that's also this the thing that i want
to cover before we go into
the structure
so on the left hand side is our
web assembly the server client side
blazer
on the right hand side is our
server-side blazer
so we can see that they look pretty very
very similar and uh
and it's all based on asp.net core so
the entry point is always the program
files and they're pretty similar too
i also covered the asp.net lifecycle
that
includes the
configuration as well as the
middleware pipeline in one of my other
videos
so this program actually this program
file
has a main method this is the entry
point of the whole application same as
the server side and
this basically builds the hosting
environment of the web application
and
the startup files are the actual uh
configuration file that we can use to
configure the uh the application
so let's actually um focus on our client
side for now so we have our program
files which calls our startup files to
configure our applications
by default there's nothing in the
configure services which handles the
dependency injection
and
there's only this adding one components
which is the root components of our
application
if we look at the
this folder it has the www root folder
we have index.html file
which
has
the basic html structure
and the most important thing the two
important thing here one is this app
loading
thing then this is the the root
component
and also
this
blazer web assembly that i have showed
you
that this this one downloads the all of
the dlls and initialize the
runtime to start running our application
so then when this page gets loaded
uh
the
app component which is root component is
being used and the root component
set up the router for the client-side
routing
all right and then
it uses the layout file
which is under
the shared folder the layout file
and it provides
a layout for our application
and the most important part here in the
layout file is this body placeholder
which is a placeholder of all of the
relatable components so the rob rotable
components are the component that has
the
for example here
has the page
add page directive
which tells the blazer framework
or toster
tells the water
that this
component is a rotable component and in
order to get to the component we can use
this rod
right we can use this path and when we
use this path what's happening is that
this
component will
will be displayed at the place where the
add body placeholder is which is inside
the main layout
so in this add body layout
sorry this is main layout
we have this add body placeholder
and if we go to slash
counter
this placeholder will be
replaced with
with
with the information here this is the
client side
structure and if we focus on the
server side
structure for now it's very very similar
the only thing
that is different is
in this startup file it has
more information here
it
configures the
default route here which is
our host file this is the entry
well that's the entry point is still the
program dot cs file but on the front end
this page is gets loaded first which has
all of the html structure just like the
index.html
in the client side
and we also have this blader server.js
js file
which
kind of
handles the
signalr communication channel
and some other tasks as well and we also
have this app component placeholder here
that
loads our root component
right and the root component basically
from this point on everything is
almost the same
if it's not exactly the same
so we goes to the main layer
we load the main layout
so
so the app component here also
configures the router
and then it loads the main layout and
the main layout also
within the shared folder we have the
main layout here and
it also has the body
placeholder it's the same mechanism that
allows
the
routable component within it
so the opposite of wrong component is
is unboundable which means that a
component that does not have that page
does not have this add page directive
so those components are basically kind
of like controls that can be
used in
um
in components in other components
so i also wanted to
draw this
project structure on whiteboard i think
it
is going to be more help
so we have this
program entry point
program.cs file entry point
um
and above that we have the startup
startup class
um
that
does the um
dependency injection
and
also
middleware pipeline setup
and about that
we have our
either is the host file or the index
the html
the host file
is for
the server side blazer and index.html is
for the client side
and
above that we have our root component
which
set up the
the rotting the client side running
and
last but not least
is our
our main layout
component
and within the main layout the most
important part is the
uh
the body
placeholder
which uh which is the placeholder for
all of the other wallable components
so
we have
c1 c2
etc
cn
and all of these are actually
will be eventually loaded into the
um
the body
placeholder one by one and
will be displayed to the to the user
and of course we also have our
unboundable components
which will be used within
the
the rotable components
and they also can be used
within each other
so that's the product structure of the
um
the both the server-side
uh
blazer as well as the web assembly
blazer
and
since we have seen that the product
structure is very very similar so
you can actually switch between
the
web assembly blazer and server side
blazer so if you
want to start with the server side
blazer because
it's production ready and the web
assembly blazer is not production ready
as of today um
april 8 2020
then you can start with the server sub
laser and until
these the clients have laser come out
and then you can easily
switch to client step laser if that's
what you want to do
if that makes sense for for the
application and for the business if you
want to switch i think the only thing
that you
um other than changing a few lines of
code and configure the program's startup
classes a little bit differently
the only thing that you need to pay
attention is to keep your components
very very thin and encapsulate the other
logic
in
in a different layer maybe in the
service layer
so
also i forgot to cover the import
dot razer file on this file
it has all of the name spaces so it uses
using
directive to import the namespaces
so it has a
a lot of these so you don't have to use
the using inside each component you can
just put it under the inside the imports
imports.razer and this will import
all of the namespaces for you and then
you can use
use the classes inside the
namespace within the components that you
want to use you don't have to use the
using in each component
so so it keeps the code very clean
data binding for blazer
so for any software that that has a ui
the software needs to do
two things
the first thing is to display
information the second thing
is
to
manipulate
the information
and we look at the data flow
okay for the first one
for this display information
we have a ui and we have data i'm just
using a database
symbol to represent data
so
it flows from the database
to
the
ui
okay so this is ui
this is ui and this is data and the
second one is data manipulation
right so we have
ui and we have data and data flows into
the ui when you
do your data manipulation
on the ui you always want to save the
data back to the data source
so from this
we know that there are two kinds of ways
for data flow one is this one weight
and this is
second is the two way
for data binding this are these are the
two ways of data binding
we have one-way data binding and two-way
data bindings but why do we even need
data binding
why can we just
program without it
yes we can
we always
need
a ui we always have a ui regardless
whether we have data binding or not we
always have a ui and we also
have
a
variable that represents the data
right
we have a variable
and
we need a variable to be displayed on
the ui
right so we load the data from the data
source to the variable and we need to
need to display the variable on the ui
right without data binding
we can manually
find the element on the ui
and
set the variable
value of the variable
into the element
so we can manually
populate the data onto the element and
once we modify we manipulate the data
within the element on the screen we can
save the data
directly back to the data source without
even going through the variable
right and if we want to load the data we
can load the data to the
to the variable
and then
again
display directly onto the element
so this is one way we can do it but that
um
you know this is a process we wanted to
to avoid
so that's why we have this thing that is
called data binding right
where we actually binds
we actually find the
the ui
element
or element
to
the data
so variable actually the variables
as if they are one right and there's two
two kind of
uh two type of data binding with one is
one-way data binding will only bind the
data
to the ui element the other is two-way
data binding obviously
we not only bind the variable to the
element but we also bind the ui elements
to the variables
so that way
whenever we look at the variables they
always
represents
the ui elements on the screen
all right so having said all of that
let's
jump into the computer and look at the
uh the codes so i created a server side
blazer project
and uh
this is the index page
i in this region under this region i
have a view model
that is a for a sales person this is the
amount
um well maybe it's a target amount or
something like that and then whether the
salesperson is active
and under which locations the sales
person is uh is active
and first of all let's uh
initialize the data
first of all let's initial data we need
to overwrite
our initialized method and in here we
are going to create a new person
new um
well
yeah yeah that's right
indexed view model
and then i will have the sales person
give it a name
and
amount
locations some default locations
all right so i have the data initialized
and uh for uh
for one-way data binding we can do
very simple thing
to display the
the salesperson's name
right so it's as simple as you know
doing
this
it's a add sign and then
you just
put the variable here
so that's why we did a binding
right and let's display a few things
um
name an amount maybe
and you can of
format the data like this
so this is one-way data binding
and if you run this code run this code
we can see
the name alex
let's have a line break here
then we save it so um so if we use ctrl
f5
to run the project instead of just uh
just a 5
then you will have
this page
once you make any changes
uh the page will detect the change from
the signal
signalr channel
and then you just do a refresh you will
see your changes reflects
reflected
so i added a
a line break which
for whatever reason wasn't displayed so
i uh i'm trying to add another one yeah
now we can see the line brick here
and uh we have this formatting here
these two are the one-way data binding
just to bind the
variable
the variables to the front end
so to implement the two-way data binding
we need to
use the bind attribute
so for example
of course if we want to manipulate data
right
we want to
let's say i want to manipulate the
amount
then we need to
bind we need to bind not only from the
variable to the
to the element to the input element but
also
we need to bind the element
to
the variable and for that we can use the
bind command
the band
the bind attribute so
we have bind value and what do we want
to bind which value do we don't bind we
want to bind the amount
right we want to do this
and then
and then here
if we do this
and we save
come over here and refresh the page
we'll see
the amount here
15 000
okay so we have this 15 000 here and if
we make a change
okay and we tab out from the text box
notice
this amount
is also is also changed accordingly
so if we change this number to 100
and tab out from the text box this
number is also changed this means what
this means that
uh
when we're changing this and type out
our change event
the uh value is
passed to the variable and then the
variable because the variable is is also
bound to this uh this place so this this
value is displayed here so this is
one-way one-way data binding this is a
two-way in the case that we want to
so in the case if when i want to uh
change the underlining variable while
i'm typing directly in
the input box
in that case i need to add another
another
vector build which is the bind value
event so
that that's trying to tell the blazer
framework
of what event or what happens
the value is
passed back to the variable and here we
want to say on input so while we are
inputting into the text box
the variables gets updated
that's what we're trying to say to the
laser framework
so once we refresh
we can see
while we're typing
the amount is passed to the underlying
variables
so here i want to say a little bit more
so if you wanted to use bind
in this case you have to use bind event
all right so if you wanted to use bind
value then in this case you have to use
bind value otherwise they're going to be
exception
so um
the next i wanted to demonstrate
checkbox checkbox
is a type equals checkbox
and here we want to bind value
don't have space
so here
bind value to percent is active i also
wanted to display
the person active
directly here
just so that we can see the changes
okay so we have this checkbox but we
don't know what it is
so we're gonna have a label
and
and here we say
is active
give us space here
refresh
all right
so we can see that it's active is false
and but when i check it you know it's
directly changed to true immediately
uncheck false so you can see the two-way
data binding for checkbox
next one we want to i want to go to
i want to go to radio buttons
for for radio buttons
it will be a little bit different
there's no
direct
uh
there's no direct
two-way binding for radio buttons we
have to kind of
you know
create our own
so the name variable is
is
is the group
indicates the group
so in here um
we would have
you know so we have
radio button one
and uh
radio button two
okay so we have this
i can see it works like
uh exclusive
selection it's within one group but we
need to add a binding to it
for that i wanted to um
perhaps just add another
variable here
i call it selected
selected group
all right
and at the beginning
nothing is selected so i changed to zero
so we'll put zero here
and uh because we don't want to select
any
checkbox uh when the screen is loaded
so we need to bind that value
to the
radio buttons and to do that we need to
use the check
checked attribute here
we can use the expression here and say
that
if the selected group
equals 1
then
we check this
and here if
the
selected group
equals two then we select this one
all right so
so in this case
we're not selecting anyone so
after a refresher screen i expect to see
that the radio buttons are not selected
right now selected by default but if i
change this to number one and i save and
refresh the screen
refresh the page i see that
i'm expecting number one to be selected
which is exactly what happened
so
next
we want to make changes to this radio
buttons
and we want this change to be
reflected in the variable selected group
how do we do that
so we can use the on
click event
so in here we can say on click
okay
and again
with
assigned and parenthesis
here we can add a arrow function
we can say that when this event happens
we call this selected group function
same thing here
equals two
when i click on number one
i want the selected group to change to
number one
and when i click on number two
i want the circuit group to change to
number two
right and here
maybe here i'll display
the selected group
refresh the screen at the beginning i'm
expecting number one being written there
yeah and change to number two
immediately
we see the change
perfect
so we cover checkbox radio buttons and
what else do we need to cover perhaps a
drop down list right so the drop down
list is simpler
simpler than radio buttons radio buttons
probably the
most difficult one
here let's bind
to a selected location right so which i
don't have a
variable here so here we're going to
create a selected location variable and
we can see that our location has an id
and we're going to bind that to id
so i'll create a selected
location id equals um 0
indicating that we're not binding to
anything at the beginning
so i have this here and then um
that's the select and for options
we want to have a for each loop
where we you know location
in person
let's give it better name so i call
location
under the person locations
variable
we have
we want to create an option element
the value is log dot id
all right
and
the
here we want to display let's display
the city
the thought is messy so after that we'll
have a list of cities but about the
beginning we wanted to be
you know
empty
yeah empty
after that it's fine
so
and we wanted to show
i wanted to show
the selected location
id here okay
so let's refresh the screen
all right so the beginning select
location is zero which is an empty
item
and i have toronto montreal
all right so i'm going to select you can
see the id changes which is pretty cool
that's basically it for drop down list
we're binding to the selected location
id
and uh the list of locations is kind of
a one-way binding to
the
drop-down list and then another way
binding back is to a different variable
select the location id
and next perhaps we want to do a list
right i want to show a list
so we would have an ordered list
and
we're doing basically it's very similar
to the down list
we want to display the location in
persons
locations
we want to have a
list and we want to show
the city
all right and we want to show
the province state and we want to show
the country
all right so we have that
now come over here and refresh
yep we have a list
so what about a table
table will be pretty similar
but i'll demonstrate more than that
so i have a table and
we want to be
using the
bootstrap
and for here we have a list of rows
and that we have for each
again we use this in
dot locations
a person.locations
and we have
we have as many rows as locations
and i want to show
everything
for the table
well and if i
save it and refresh
i've i've lost
a table
and that's a list of countries in the
table
but what if we wanted to create a table
that
it actually updates the underlining data
for that what do we do
so of course we can change this to an
input
let's use this a city for example
we change to input
and then the type is text
right
and
um
if we do
bind
to
bind value
if we say
bind to what
i bind to
uh
location.city
let's see what happens if we do this
refresh
as you can see
it's working
right and
if we want we can change the bind event
to
oh
input
and
yep
so we have it
only in here as well pretty cool
right so if we change copy all of this
to actually uh let's give it a class
to be a
form control
that looks pretty good
and let's
copy this
to replace
post this
and the country
and then
we just need to change this to
profs state
changes to country
and
all right there we have it
so we can change this to some other city
right
new york
and
new york
usa
so you can see that
it's updated here also in the drop a
drop down list
so
and if we have a submit button
right
then once we submit
we can handle the submit event
and
we can look at the locations and we have
all of the changes in that variable so
this is the beauty of data binding
we don't need to manually go into each
one of them
to grab the data
we have the data already
when we're handling
the click event of a submit button
in blazer random programming is
component based
which is in line with
other frontend framework or libraries
like angular react
vue.js
a web page consists many components like
header
sidebar page component
or maybe some reusable components inside
the page component
and footer as well
traditionally websites consist of pages
and reusable areas within pages are
called controls
a name that
comes from the desktop application
programming realm
later simplifies things
and use components represents both
pages
and controls
to distinguish the two
let's call them page components and then
page components
so if you create a
blazer application
the default application that comes from
the visual studio templates it looks
like this i added a sales component here
but if we go through this
we have
four pages here
the home counter fast data and sales the
sales one is the one that i added
so
um
we'll go to home page
right we can see this highlighted area
is a page component
counter
this
highlighted area is also a page
component
same as this
and the sales component that i added
so which part is a reusable num page
component it is
the area that highlighted in blue so
let's jump into the computer visual
studio
and
take a look at
some
demo about page component
as well as
numpage component
so
let's add a page component first we can
see that a page can
there is a page folder already so these
components are page components except
this
uh
this entry point file right so to add a
page component we'll go to page right
click on page footer
and we click on
click on new adam
select reader component
and then
give it a name
remember to make sure that
the first letter is capitalized
let's call it
sales component
i always want to append component
this word
at the end of the the name
just to to make sure
when you later create classes for
example if you want to create sales
it does not cause a namespace conflict
so
so we have sales
component
all right so we have sales component
here because the sales component is a
page component so we have to be able to
navigate to the sales component
so in order to
be able to never get to the sales
component we use the page directive
and actually before we do this we can
take a look at the other ones right so
fetch data we have the the page
directive
and slash fascida which means that when
we um
have the url that that says
domain name slash fetch data it will go
to this uh fetch data component same as
the counter component
when you say slash counter it will go to
the counter component so when you want
to go to our sales component i want to
i want the
url to be slash sales
okay so in this component i will do
nothing
and then uh let's navig let's make
ourselves navigate to the sales
component through the manual
and let's call this this is the the url
this is the routing path
right so we have the fetch data sales
counter
so this basically means when we click on
this navigation link it goes to
the counter component
here when you click on this link go to
the fast data component and we can click
on sales it goes to the
the sales component
so if you
watched my video about the product
structure i've covered uh the project
structure there
uh if this is a little bit confusing
about
the navigation link and how
all of the files work together you can
go back to
one of the previous episodes about
project structure where i covered that
part
so here
i have added the
navigation link here
uh and i've added the component
it's the sales component and make sure
that the
uh the routing path is sales
right so
then
in the
the body part
when we
when we input in the url slash
sales
the body placeholder will display our
sales component
okay let's give it a try right it's
right here so we click on sales
sales component
right
and if we are not sure whether that's
our component
we can add some
thing here
okay so this is
save
else here refresh
so we get this this is the sales
component
so this is our component a page
component
is also
called a writable component
which is highlighting the fact that
we're able to rot
to the component by using the
the rotting path
here i also want to cover
rotting for a page component a page
component must be audible meaning that
you have to be able to access the page
component
by following a url right so we already
talked about this a little bit
uh
but i also wanted to point out that you
can have multiple one page component you
can have multiple
uh
rot
right so if i added this and go to our
page and refresh
by the way what i did is i did ctrl f5
right so that way after you add it you
can do you can refresh your page and
then
all of the changes will be picked up
so we have salesperson and add another
route
which is
salesperson
right so we can use both sales and
and sales person
to go to the same page component
however
uh it's only a one-to-many relationship
from
page to routes
it's not the other way around
meaning that if you want to use the same
um
the same rod
in a different page
it's going to give you an error for
example
if i copy the sales person
rod and put it under counter
inside counter
and
if i refresh here see it's going to tell
me that
the following rods
are duplicate we have two pages that
have the same
bots
and those two page components are sales
component and counter component
so the error message is actually very
informative
and the moment you remove this is going
to work again fresh all right so that's
working again
so i want to just cover a little bit
about how the page how the routing works
when we put when we use the page
directive
for each page component
and provide a path to the page component
we are basically applying a rod
attribute
to
the page class
so if you have used
if you have created web api
or
mvc
in asp.net or asp.net core
you know that
you can use
a
rod attribute
for a class you can you can decorate a
class
with a
rod attribute when these components are
compiled
they are turned into
c-sharp classes
and they would basically look something
like this
right so you would have your whole
component
the raw facet is
root
root fast right and you counter
with this rod you fast shade it with
this rod and the sales component we just
created was this rod
so
when the
laser framework
is
loaded
it actually loads all of your component
sort of another list
right it doesn't create a component yet
but it lowers the metadata of these
components into a list
it knows that you have these components
it knows that which component has which
rod
and then when you are
using
different urls
by inputting them into the broader
address bar or you're navigating
inside
by using the nav link
it's going to go through that list
and look for a component that has that
rot
and then it will initialize that
component
and if it cannot find it
see the app component actually says
uh
router and if it's not found it's going
to say sorry there's nothing
at this address
and if it sees that there are two
components
that are the same
rod it's gonna spit out an error so for
a none page component a numpage
component the purpose of having a
numpage component
is to encapsulate some
functionalities whether the component is
reusable or not
right we don't want to write component
with thousands of lines of code
we want to be able to encapsulate
certain functionality within different
components
so that it's easier to manage
and if they are reusable then it's even
better so in this case let's create a
component
that tells us time so to do that i like
to call the reusable component controls
right
but i i just put them into a controls
folder
although i still call them component
and then we're gonna display it
right here
and we're gonna
display
in this format
okay so
we have this and we know the namespace
is
the
the root namespace
plus control plus the folders so we want
to
add that namespace here so we're going
to say
laser
demo
dot controls
and to use that
let's say we want to use that
in our
newly created sales component
to reference to
to use the page numpage component
we can just declare them as
by using html element syntax
so we're pretending
the
the component that we have
is a
html element
and so here
and that's all we need to do
so
i would add a
two of them
then we go to our
share do a refresh all right so we have
our
daytime here today is may 3rd
sunday
toronto ontario canada all right so we
covered page component we covered none
page component
uh
as you have noticed
that our numpage component does not
require
a page directive
right
another thing i want to also mention is
that
you can also use a page component
as
uh
as a reusable numpage component for
example i want to show the counter
right inside the sales component so what
do i do
i just declare it here it's very easy
i just say
counter
right that's it
and let's go to here
and refresh
all right so we have so
as you can see if i go to counter i see
the counter component if we go to sales
i also see the counter component
and it works
okay now let's cover component structure
a component
has basically
two areas
one is the
the html markup
and the other part is the c-sharp code
blocks
right you can have more than one of this
you can have you know
two still works
right so you can separate them so this
part covers some functionality and this
part can cover different functionality
you can use this to do it
so the html markups obviously
it defines the look and view
and the c sharp code blocks
it
contains ui logic
so let's take alex i have no logic here
uh let's take a look at the
counters
right so
here this place some
some dynamic information this is the
title so these are all for look and view
right and here defines a button and then
when the button is clicked
we uh we increment
the
the variable
so
so when we combine the c sharp code
blocks along with the html markup
together
they
dynamically render the component now
let's talk about component inheritance
so let's say that all of our components
have a common property and let's just
say that property is called date right
because all of our components want to be
able to display data so in that case
what do we do do we declare a date
variable
inside all of our components
so that would be um
code duplications and we don't
want that
so what we can do is
of course yeah we did this part did this
way
but if we want to use that date
uh variable
not only for display but also for some
other
logic process
then we have to be able to reference
that variable inside each one of the
components
so how do we do that
we don't want to create a variable
inside each component we want to be able
to inherit it from
a base component blader supports
inheritance
so let's create a base component
it's basically a c-sharp class maybe
let's call it the time
based component
and what do we have here
is a basically a property
that is a date time
and uh
let's call it
daytime
so another thing that we need to make
sure that
our component
needs to
be based on
need to derive from component base and
if i do ctrl dot
it will generate that
using statement there
now let's use this
uh
base component
let's go to our sales component and
in here
we want this page
to derive this page component to to
derive
from
our
uh daytime
based component
which we have to actually do the
uh
using statement here we can
we don't have to do it in the
imports.reader
we can do it directly in here but
because i did it
so we can access the class name directly
here
so we are inheriting from
uh
we make the sales component inherit from
the datetimebase component
and let's delete these confusing lines
and let's just use the uh
let's just display
the datetime
variable right here
right and
in order to make sure
that we have it
i put the date label here
all right so as we can see
we have this
right here well it doesn't have it's uh
the value was not initialized so it
would be the minimum
date time here
laser programming is component based
as was covered in the previous episode
and you would have page components and
non-page components
right
so for example you would have
page one
page two
page three
page and
each page may deserve to have sub
components
and those components are non-page
components
for example this page
one has two sub components
and page two does not have any sub
components or none page components and
page three is even more complicated
and has
you know
a component tree like this
and
page a may have something like that
so
now the interesting happens
interesting thing happens
so now when we have a complicated
structure like this
what needs to happen is a communication
between these components
and
the communications between the page
components
this kind of communications
are done
by passing rotting parameters
rotting parameters
and the communications between
the parents
and child
this is done
by
parameters regular parameters
rotting
parameters
rotting
parameters
and this is also rotting
parameters
but these ones are regular parameters
all right so this is also
and this is also
right
so these are
regular parameters
so we have
rotting parameters
and we have regular parameters
and the third type of parameters
are
cascading valid parameters
so in that case uh we have a
a deeper
tree
structure like
page three
and sometimes we want to pass the value
down from
the parent from the page component all
the way to the leaf
right
all the way to all of them
and we can do that by using the regular
parameters
right all of that
can be done
but
laser
has a better way to do that it's called
cascading parameters i'm not sure
whether i'm spelling correctly or not so
another type of communication is that
when the child
when the child when the children are
trying to tell the parents
about something some interesting that
happens
right for example your child
calls you from university about
something
right and you would have to react to it
so that kind of
is called event callback that kind of
communication so this
is event callback
right these blue ones are event
callbacks
and another type of communication is
when you want to tell your child about
something right when you call your child
about something happen something
interesting happen
and you ask your child to do something
and that kind of communication
is
um
is when the parents
calls the child this type of
thing we reference
you know we reference the child
component
and then we can call a method on that
child component directly
what you're looking at is a standard
visual studio template for blazer
server-side application and i added a
few components but today we're going to
look at the sales component which is
empty
and the order entry
component
which is currently also empty
in order to see them they're both page
components and as you can see i give
them different
roth and the page the order entry
uh
component uses the order
slash order rot and the sales
component uses slash sales block
and in order to see them
we are going to add the navigation
links copy
two of them
and then
this i'm going to call it sales
and this
we call it order entry
and i'm going to change the route
to sales and this is going to be order
and we if we go back here and refresh
we're going to see
sales
and order entry
and what these two represent
are
the sales represents sales department
and the order entry
uh represents the order entry depend
department both of them are page
components
so um as you can see if you have many
department
you might want to consider
having this title part as a component by
itself
right so let's do that
let's create a
numpage component and as you know i have
a habit of calling it controls
but you don't have to call it controls
and i'm going to create a new
component razer component and call it
a
title component
and this is none page component so it
doesn't have a rot
but what we're gonna put here is
we're going to go to the page component
and copy one of them
uh it's basically this
right and we're going to come over here
and then we'll say
welcome to the
and we're going to change this part
dynamically
right so we're going to give it um
we're going to give it a a variable here
in order to
populate that but it's not just any
variable cannot be private a variable
because this variable has to be
available to the to the parent
component so it has to be public
in order
to
allow the parent component to access
this variable it has to be a special
variable and
it has to be a property
and it has to be a public property and
we call it
uh we can call it
department
right and here we have to use a
parameter attribute
to let later know that this property
department
is a
public parameter that can be accessed
from
the consumer which is the parent
component
right and then we can use this
over here
or actually over here and we can say
department
right and then when we use that
component in the parent component
we can do
this
as i have shown in the previous episode
we can use the child component as
actually
in order to do that i'm going to
import
the
namespace
and then i'm going to come over here
and
i'm going to type in
title component which
is right here
and as you can see
the parameter is right here okay and
then in this case it is sales
okay i'm gonna copy this code
and i'm gonna go over to order energy
department and
i'm gonna call it
order entry
this way
when we go to our code and hit refresh
we're going to have the sales
and water entry department represented
by our one
component our title component
and the good thing about that is if you
want to change
the wording
or the style or the theme or whatever
um
of the title
you can change it from one place right
so we can go to our title component
and um
if we want to add
for example you want to want to be
in the scored
we can have this and then we go back
refresh as you can see the underscore is
right there
right if we want to change the font
color
to
actually change change to uh
header
we wanted to
change the
fun color
to
blue
dark blue
then we can change it to dark blue like
this and then we go back
and we refresh there we have it
changing in one place passing in
parameters
so to
some to sum up
in order to pass a parameter from the
parent component to the child component
we need to create a pro public property
and decorate it with parameter attribute
and then we use our component child
component in the parent
by declaration
and
populate the parameter
with the value that you want to use
so the rod parameters are used to help
us communicate between page components
as well as
between
none page component and page component
to demonstrate
i created
teams component and
team component
right the teams component the list of
teams and the team component is detail
of that team and also showing the member
of that team
and uh
in order to display them because
currently we don't see it on the menu so
in order to display them um i am going
to
also added the navigation menu
uh just like last time
but
make sure we have proper route when we
come to the navigation menu we clean up
this a little bit we change this to
teams
and we change this to teams as once we
refresh the page we can go to our teams
and
we see a list of teams and for now
let's take a look at the codes that i
have so
so i basically have a teams variable
here and i initialize the variable and
popular hard-coded some values here
and i created this uh team class here
usually
all of these
should be
created separately as models and
dependency injection into the razor
components but
since i haven't covered dependency
injection
so i'm hardcoding these over here
what my expected behavior is
is that when we click on
any of these teams we go to the team
component the team page component and
display the detailed information about
that particular team that you clicked on
our code here
our markups html markups we can see that
i used for each loop and created the uh
the rows within the tables and it's
displaying team and team
team region and also i have a
anchor
element here
going to the the team page component
so when i click on it it goes to team
component unfortunately
uh every single one of them got a team
one team component is empty right so
let's go to our team component
over here
and uh it has pre-populated some codes
but it does nothing
as i said that these should be created
as models and dependency injection into
the razer components but i'm just hard
coding it right right now so don't worry
too much about them
so
i want to display the detailed
information about the team as well as
the members so i have these
data here to kind of represent the
member
database table
right so you have a list of members and
you know um
you know
uh
the
you know the ids of them
and you also
should have
a
the team team id
right
to indicate which team the member belong
to
so for that i'm going to create a
team id
property and then i'm going to go over
here and
populate that property team id equals
one
and i'm going to
let them
to become different teams
all right
so
but the thing is how do we pass that
uh
information about which team we have
selected
that's
where the rod parameters come into the
picture
so in order to do that so here
we can say that
basically here we can say slash team
and then we give the team dot
the id
slash
all right so that gives the proper rod
parameter here
so
if we go back here
we can see that
at the bottom left corner
you can see each one of them
has a
team id appended
at the url
right
but the thing is when you click on it
it's going to say
it's
you know there's nothing at this address
right so
we have to change our team component to
accept that parameter and to do that
it's actually pretty easy we come over
here and we say
you know
this is i'm not expecting a id parameter
uh and then we come over here and we
create a corresponding property and we
call it id
right and
within here you can say parameter
and uh
and this corresponds to the id right
and let's see what happens when we do
this
all right
refresh click on it
all right so we have received a uh
exception and
so what is happening
let's um take a look at the
uh developer tool
so it's complaining that unable to set
property id on the object of
team component the error was unable to
cast object type
string to integer okay so
that is telling us that it's considered
as a string but we are expecting an
integer so what do we do in that case we
set up a constraint
here we're saying okay i'm expecting
integer
right so if another way to do it is that
we can change this to
integer
sorry change this from
uh integer to string so let's do that
and then we refresh all right so now
we're going to team
to the team component but we're not
loading any data yet
at least we're passing that property
right
we can say
you know we can say over here we
pass in that id
let's display that id
refresh the page okay
it will properly pass it in the id
from uh the teams page to the team page
so that's the communication between
different pages
right so in order to properly properly
display the page uh
we we can come over here and we can say
that
you know uh
i'm
searching through
the uh
you can use link to query the teams
variable that i have it here
we can say that
if the id equals
uh this dot id which is our
parameter block parameter
then that's the theme that we are
looking for
right
and
it gives an error here right because uh
this is a string and
this by itself is integer
right this is integer so it doesn't want
to do that so let's change it to integer
and then we will add the parameter
constraint
and we're telling that we're telling
blazer that this parameter is an integer
right so so now this is fine so we will
have our team so once we have our team
we come over here and we say that the uh
you know the name is
team dot
dot name
intellisense is
not great yet
it seems that it's a little bit slow
so here we can have
a region
right and let's see whether that works
or not so i saved and then i refresh
okay let's go to red team so we have
right team here properly the parameters
properly passed in and our link query
is also working
okay cool um
all right next is that we we're trying
to display the members right and we're
going to create another
place here and then we are going to find
our members first
which is uh we have it here and we need
to find
all of the members
so the members are
from the members i want to find
the members who
belong to
the team so team id equals
this dot id
which this id again is the parameter
value the raw parameter value so then we
would have all of the members right so
we'll have our members here and then
we'll come over here and say for each
sorry um
actually
so here we want to uh display it in the
list
to save some time instead of displaying
a table and here we're going to have for
each
and we're going to have variable member
in the staff members
and
here we're going to say our i
and we're going to say number dot name
well um
pipeline
member dot
uh
h
intellisense
what else do we have yeah name and age
and that's good
and then let's see
when we refresh our page
so go to our right team
we have
team name is rad region is region one
and john's h is 20 mike's age is 25.
going back two teams got a blue team and
we have joe 26 ross21
and yellow we have ryan 23 and fox 22.
so
there we go we have uh parameters
passing as raw parameters and going to
the different page from parent
from teams page to team page and we are
successfully load data and display data
based on the passing raw parameters
let's talk about cascading parameter uh
so
if we have a
component three like this
where i have the page component that
contains several levels of component
so these component
these components
make the tree a little bit
complicated
so in this case
if we want to pass the parameter value
from the first level from the page level
down
to the leaf
if we want to use the regular parameter
we have the passive parameters as many
times as
the number of levels
that the component tree has so one way
that microsoft has came up with to solve
this problem is
they created something that is called
cascading parameter it's something that
you can use
to cascade a value from whichever level
downward
to the lower level components
you don't have to cascade one by one
okay let's jump to the computer and see
how it's implemented all right
and this is a standard template
blazer template it comes from microsoft
and we go to the counter page you can
see when we click on it
the current column increases so we're
going to modify this
to
mimic a scenario where we have many
levels of components we're going to
create another two level so all together
we have three levels so this is the
counter component let's
uh create two more components
let's create two more components
let's call it component one
and component 2.
and in order to distinguish them i'm
going to add some
css cell
so
we're gonna add some margin
um
to component one
and then we're to add another margin
to
component 2
which will cause some indentation so
that we can see the different levels so
with this we are instead of displaying
the current count
inside the counter component
we are going to remove this
and we are going to display the counter
con in the component number two
right but before we do that um
we are going to
add the
components in
we have component one
and then
within component one
we add
component
two
right so component one contains
contaminant two
and
counter component
contains component one
right
so if we
uh refresh our page
right so we're gonna see
component one component two like this
was the margin indicating the different
levels of components so uh
now i wanna display the uh
counter value inside component
2 right how do we do that
we need to wrap our components
with a cascading
value
element
and we're going to tell
that
i'm going to tell blazer that this value
is called counter and the value itself
comes from the current
the current count
and we wrap this component one with it
so current count is here so what happens
is that when we click
on the button it calls this event
handler and it increases the count and
this current count is passed into
the component tree
no matter how deep the tree is
how many how many levels the tree has
you can access
this
count value from within the components
so
let's say you want to access from
component two you can actually access it
from component one or component two or
both right so
uh in this video let's directly go to
component two and we're trying to
display the count here
right so let's say
i want um tell
that the count
as
the count
is
is the the corner value
right and to do that we need to
declare a
parameter and that is the same type
um
and the name can be any name let's call
it contour
value
but
the
we have to
decorate it with this cascading
parameter and we call it
sorry the talent
name of this custom parameter is counter
right that's the same name that we give
it
here
right so
you can name your
cascading parameter
with
anything
but then as long as you declare that the
in the attribute part that you make sure
that this counter value name is the same
with the name that you declared
inside the cascading value element
all right so now with this setup you
would be able to rate this counter value
directly from
the contour component the parent
component
uh the ancestor component
okay
it will contain this value so let's see
whether we'll get it
to get the correct value so we're gonna
display this value right here
counter
value
and then we're going to go back and
refresh our page
right so now it shows counter value 0
and we need to increase
when we increases
it goes up okay so we have successfully
passed down the counter value so this
helps us a lot
when we want to pass values around
component 3
it's very convenient one of the
disadvantages of this
is that
when you have
when you need to pass the values around
all of the components in the component
tree the blazer framework would have to
monitor all of the components you use
just one cascading
value that you want to cascade
then
the blazer would have to monitor all of
the components if you want to pass the
value to all the components for example
uh about a theme a theme of your
application once you set it
it has to be accessed by all the
components
and the component
each one of the components will monitor
monitor the change of that
uh theme once it changes
then
each every one of the component will
change
so this kind of
makes the um laser framework have too
much to handle right if you have just
one variable to cascade
it adds a lot of work
and then you have two
then it has more work
that's three then has even more work
so by the way let's see how um we want
to cascade
multiple parameters how do we do that
okay so let's do that first and then
we'll come back to the drawback to the
um
to one of the problem was this and how
we can fix this and how we can fix this
um kind of a performance issue
right because
when blazer has too much to monitor it
takes too much resources and it costs
performance issues especially with
blazer server side
that the uh it monitors
each user has its own session
and uh it holds the session state and
everything so that's um if you give it
more work was uh with the cascading's
parameters it's gonna create more
performance issues so we're gonna go
come back in in the film
in a minute
let's
see how we can implement multiple
cascading parameters so let's go to
counter
and uh
let's
just uh cascade
let's say we want to change
the the color
of that
so
we would add another level of cascading
parameter and we call it
you know we call it
uh let's say um
color and value is
i'm going to directly
give it a value
right here
let's say the
value is
is blue
okay
and now we can go to our
component
child component
we can just color declare another
cascading parameter
and making sure that the title matches
and here it doesn't matter you just call
it color
and then
we are going to modify the
the color
right we call it
we call this color
value here
and
if we refresh we're expecting the level
2 component i mean component 2 becomes
blue refreshing
it's not blue and why is that
title counter
title color
oh
tito
color
all right so it's blue
all right so we're
now we're actually cascading multiple
uh levels sorry multiple cascading
parameters multiple values
so
let's go back to the point that i was
trying to make about the performance
issue
so um
and this is actually a good example that
we are cascading
a color
to down to the component too
right
but
it's static
means that it's not changing like the
counter
the count value
it increases or decreases
uh it's static
it's fixed
so
but even though it's fixed because we
have
we have the clarity that's getting
parameter here laser framework will
still try to monitor this and and try to
see whether this color will change but
it's actually not going to change
but this is actually a text resource
from
uh from the laser framework
right
so it will actually impact the
performance
so one way we can avoid this is to come
over here and say
you know
uh this is a fixed
this is the fixed
value
so when we go back and refresh it's not
gonna affect it it's gonna still work
you're gonna not you're gonna you're not
gonna see any differences
but
um
but it's gonna avoid the performance
impact
so this is what you need to do when you
need to cascade a fixed parameter for
example if you have different
departments right you have water
department your sales department you
have different departments and
if
each department has its own page
component and each page component has
its own complicated complicated
component tree
but
inside those inside the two component
trees you you want those child
components to know about which page
component you're in i'm in the order
department
componentry or i'm in the
sales department componentry i want to
know the department right so this type
of value
although it changes when you click on
you will never get to the the page
component but it will once you are there
it never changes
so in this case you should
use the is fixed equals to 2
to top laser framework that the value
of the cascading parameter will never
change
so this will
will not impact the performance will not
affect the performance so that's
something we need to pay attention to
another thing we need to know about is
that
cascading parameter it can only you can
only casting it down you cannot pass the
value upward
so one way to resolve that issue is to
add some event callback or add a
delegate parameter
basically a regular
component parameter
that is declared as a delegate and then
from the parent
we register to the delegate
and
when you click on the button you
trigger that alligator basically you
trigger that function inside a parent
component and then your parent component
react to that
handles that delegate and increases the
counter
increases the variable in the defined in
the parent component so that's one way
to do it but um
if you have many levels you have to pass
you have to declare that delegate
parameter for many levels up to the top
components right and that's uh that's a
pretty
in my opinion that's not a very good way
to do it uh if we go down that rod i
would uh suggest to use a uh centralized
state management which i'm going to
cover in later
episodes
so that's the other thing i want to
the other point that i want to make
which is that we cannot pass
parameters
up the component tree
of another thing that we really need to
pay attention when we use cascading
parameter is that it can quickly become
pretty messy right so when you have a
when you have a complicated uh
component tree like this
you can have
the cascade you can just declare that
consequent parameter
cascading value element on any levels
and then
on any lower levels you can receive that
with different names and if you can if
you
you come over here for example you click
on this
and you say okay i want to i want to
know where does value come from
right so you can't right click and go
definition because it will not go
anywhere right this is defined right
here
you click on it
you know it's it's you can follow it you
don't know where it's defined
right so when you have many many levels
so this is not as many levels as this is
not too complicated but when you have
many levels um when you have very big
trees you don't even know where it's
defined
right and you have to use search
uh in in your ide to find it in your
visual studio to find it which is not as
pleasant it can quickly become pretty
messy
so um again
in in those cases where you want to
uh use um
when you have what you find yourself
that you declare you find yourself
declaring a lot of
cascading parameter values
cascading parameters
that's probably a sign to tell you that
you should use a centralized
state management
system instead of using the cascading
map
parameters so we should really use the
cascading parameters
sparingly
event callbacks
are for communication between parent and
child component
and it's when the child component has
something interesting happens
then it basically calls
their parents and say
hey parent i have something interesting
happen please react to it let's take the
contour component as example let's run
the default application
uh go to common components click on
click me then it increa increases the
value
and
if we change it a little bit
uh so that the counter component because
becomes a sub component
then we can demonstrate the event
callback so
let's create another component
let's call it
a
parent component
and lab disk parent component
to use the same
route
of course we have to remove this route
so we can
make the counter component itself
becomes a sub component because it
becomes a
child component of this parent component
and
we use it like this
and if we run this code
refresh right here it's basically going
to do the same thing except you're going
to see a title here it's
parent component because
now the common component becomes a sub
component because becomes a child
component and it work the same way
but what if we want this current count
to be displayed
um
inside the parent component instead of
under the counter component itself
uh so
for that we can remove this
we remove this
and then we come over to
the parent component and
we declare
a variable here
and we call it
private
integer
count
okay
so and then go back to counter component
and
and then here we declare a
public property
okay and
we have to make sure
that the
it
it's the event callback
okay
and
with a parameter and the parameter value
is
uh parameter type is integer and we call
this
set
current
count
and this has to be a parameter
and then we are going to
invoke
this set current count
under the event handler of the increment
count
right so basically we're gonna say
invoke async
and
it's current count
then we're going to come over here and
refresh the screen and then
of course we didn't do we didn't hook it
up yet but let's try that
okay
and we are not seeing any exceptions
so keep that in mind then we'll come
back and talk about that
so in order to implement this we need to
go back to the parent component
and then
we're basically come over here and set d
parameter the side current count
as a
basically you can just say
second account
and then in here
we're gonna have this stack current
count
with integer
value and then
we are going to say
current count equals value
and what we're going to do is we're
going to display
i'm going to display this
current count right here
current count
current count
then we're going back over here
refresh all right so current column
initial is zero neutral value is zero
and then we click on it
now it works
all right so coming back and just to
summarize that
so first of all you need to do is that
you need to create a
parameter
that has a special return value
which is a event callback
this type is event callback
there's two versions of this this first
version is without the
generic type
the second version is with a generic
type depends on whether you want to pass
a parameter to it or not so this is
basically the parameter type of this
set current count
right so when you invoke it
this current count parameter has to be
this type integer type in this case
the second step so once you declare the
parameter like this then you go to your
parent account
and then you basically set the parameter
just as any other
parameters except that this is a
function name instead of just a value it
corresponds to this you can call it
any
function
it doesn't matter doesn't have to be the
same as the parameter name
and uh
if we refresh the screen you're going to
see it's going to work
anyways doesn't have to be
exactly the same
right so those are the two things uh
it's two basic things we need to know
about it
uh and then we just dig a little bit
deeper into this event
callback so the event callback is not
just any parameter
it has a special type and this
makes us kind of think that it's similar
to a
delegate in c sharp
right but it is very similar
uh to
delegate but it's not exactly the same
as a delegate for example you don't have
to when you invoke it you don't have to
test whether it's
uh empty or not
right it's not going to throw an
exception
if it's
empty right we have seen that so let's
try that again if we remove this which
means that we are not actually
providing any registration to that
delegate
if we call it delegate
it's not even a delegate but
when we rush this it's not throwing any
exceptions right it just doesn't work
anymore
right so let's put that back
so coming back over here so it's not a
delegate that you have to
check the whether it's registered or not
you can just directly invoke it and it's
going to work
secondly
it's different from a delegate because
we can actually
declare a delegate right now
right so we can declare a delegate
like
this
and uh
basically we can do the same thing let's
simulate this
uh
with
you know set count let's call it sitcom
and then over here we can declare this
as a parameter as well
and then when we go to the parent
component
we can
we can give that
delegate
assigned to the same function
right
and then if we remove this
and then we'll go to the counter
component and instead of calling this
we just call
setcount
dot invoke
we're passing the
current count
right
let's see how whether it works or not
okay
if it works then there's no difference
between a delegate and event callback
you see there's it doesn't work
i'm clicking on the click me button but
it doesn't work
why
because
your parent component you're basically
triggering this event
from a child component
and expecting your parent component to
truly render
right but it doesn't re-render
the value is set but it doesn't
re-render re-render
and the reason is that
your component does not render
if the event is triggered from from
other components
learn as you specifically say that you
want to re-render it but if we are using
a event callback
then
the
whoever whichever function
that is connected
or assigned to that event callback
your parent component is going to watch
that and once that function is called
it's going to re-render the component
but in order to make this
work
we have to
say hey state has changed
right
because this function is currently
assigned to the set count delegate
and the second delicate when the set
delicate invokes
this function is not going to trigger a
render and unless we are
specifically saying that
we know the status changed and go ahead
to rerender and now let's see what
what happens right
so now it works
so
that's why it's different
and another thing that we can try is
that if we remove this
and see what happens
if we remove this
and then we click on it immediately with
a c
and handout exception has occurred see
the broader dap tools for details
why
let's see that bother
the browser tools and then at the bottom
the console actually let's look at the
console here
it says no reference why let's go back
and take a look at our
child component
where we
invoking the delegate
without having the delegate assigned to
a actual
function right so there's no
there's no registration
to that delegate
so we can just invoke like this but
for event callback we're okay we can
just call it whether there is a
whether there is a
registration to this event callback or
not
all right
so going back here
and
set current count it pulls
well if we don't set anything
refresh again
but it doesn't work but it doesn't cause
any problems
so that's uh that's the difference
sometimes from the parent component we
want to directly invoke the methods or
properties
of the
child components outside of the
declaration
so
for example some event happened you want
to
trigger some other things
under the
under your child component
let's take example uh very quickly let's
create a
let's create a chart component
uh actually it's going to be a control
so
let's create a folder and call it
and chose and then under here let's
create a
new razer component just call it child
component
we are going to be displaying the child
component under the counter component
and
let's have a line break here and then
let's call it
let's call the chalk component right
here
uh
right here well let's
that's ugly let's
import our name space right here
um
let's play the three dot controls
so
then we go back and delete this and we
call it
child component
and
now if we refresh the screen
we'll see our child component right
there and
under under here and uh uh what we want
to do is that we want to we only want to
display the child component when we
click on the button
all right so uh
extra line break
and then uh we're gonna have a
button
and
we're gonna have
and now we want to when we click on the
button we want to display it so uh
basically means that we are not going to
display
whatever markup that we have
uh
at the beginning so we're going to
declare a
number here that says it's a boolean and
we're going to say and call it display
and we are only going to display
this
if it's true
right so we're going to put this
right here
and then we go back
and uh
this button
would complete that button later
so if we refresh then we don't see that
we see this empty button here but that's
okay
so the important thing is that we're not
seeing that child component anymore so
we want to click on the button
and
uh to show the
the child component
and over here we're going to say unclick
and what we want to do
is we want to
display
the child component we are going to say
here we're going to how do we set the
display variable under the child
component
that's where the uh
referencing child components come into
place so how to do that is that we do
we say reference and we say
you know child
and then over here we create a attribute
and we say
child component
and
child so this name
and this
they have to be the same
and then we can use this to reference
the child component so we can inside
here
right we can say child dot
uh something right so what do we do we
go to the child component
and
we create a public
method you say show
and then just say you know display
equals
then going back to the counter component
and then we say child
so when we click that button
we reference the child we say
show yourself
my child
okay so go back
and refresh
now we're gonna see that button
this button is using bulma so i do have
vomit here
and this
button is
controlled by bulma
it's using the bulma class but i haven't
referenced the bulma and they're the
host you can see that
i have
this
but i don't have bulma
right
so as soon as i
reference boma
then it's going to be
displayed
uh
yeah we're gonna take effect
refresh again all right that's boma
style and i like boma much better so in
future demos i'm going to use boma for
developing components
actually today as well
so
now you can see that we are not seeing
that child component but if i click on
it it's going to
trigger that child component show method
and uh set it to true so
the child component is going to show
itself okay so the reason why the child
component is not showing
again we talked about this in the last
in the previous episode it's that's
because the component will only render
itself
in four under four different conditions
first is when the component is created
it's just created
secondly
is when parameter changes parameter
value changes
thirdly
when there's event uh handlers for
example you click on that button and
then under that event handler you change
the state of the
component and that component is gonna
gonna re-render itself
and force
fourthly uh
that's when the developer want to
re-render the component
by
calling the state has changed method
so
because we didn't call the status change
method and because we are calling the
show method from outside of the
component or within the component
right
uh if you had a button right in the
child component and then you triggered a
show method and then you change the
property you change the state of the
child component
then the child component will
will be re-rendered
but in this case we have to specifically
as a developer we have to specifically
call the status change
and then
it will render itself
so let's refresh
you see when i click on it shall
component shows
right so go back
uh
every time we we never get to a
component
it recreated it's recreated
so now you don't see the child component
but when i click on it now it's jokes
all right so let's have even um a better
example let's
let's create a
dialogue with with boma style and then
we
we kind of toggle it right so let's go
to bulma
and uh let's go to
yeah bowman model dialog and let's go to
model and what i want is this model card
and it looks like this and it's pretty
clean and uh
in order to show
the model dialog
you can see that in order to so to
activate the model just add this active
modifier to the model container right
so
we're going to copy this
and then we are going to create another
component we're going to call it
gonna call it uh
dialog
component
right and then over here we're gonna
remove this and have this over here
we're gonna actually add this is
active active
right there and but
we are not gonna change the class
what we're gonna do is we're gonna have
again the same same sort of thing
i'm gonna have this and uh
uh we're gonna initialize it was false
and
and get over here and say hey if
you display is true then
then we display otherwise
we are not going to display anything
right
so
go
over to counter and
remove child component
we are going to say
uh we are going to reference
we are going to add the dialogue
component
right here
and
we want to reference the dialog
component by
using the name dialog and
over here we're going to say dialog
component
dialogue
and
we're going to trigger this right here
but it doesn't have the show method yet
let's go to our dialog and create a
short method
public void
show
this
display it goes to
and
we can also have our
close method right over here and call us
display
false
and another thing is that here's a
button
you see this button it's a close uh it's
a close button and we also need to
make sure that we close this as well and
we're going to call
on click
right and
again
we're going to have
our
uh
i'm going to call this and
we're going to say
close i'm going to call the close method
that we just created
and
and we know that this is not going to
work
because we have to say state
has changed
all right and we get over here and call
this as well
now
we go to
the
counter component we refresh it
um
actually we should change the name to
show dialog
go to counter
and we change the name to
show
dialog
and come back refresh again
and then click on it
we see the dialog
right
well it's not doing anything but we
click on this button yes it closed
so
going back to dialog component and get
over here and we also call this um
uh let's just
to make it simple we just call
closed like this
right and
of course on these
event handlers we should actually do
more than just closing but for today's
demo we just only call the close my
third and that's everything we do
for today
let's go back and refresh the screen
all right so we have this and these
buttons work as well as well as the
close button
this is the documentation from microsoft
regarding the templated component and
there are three key factors within a
templated component
the first one is
render fragment
right this type of parameter the second
one is a parameter that is a generic
type list
and the third one is a render fragment
with a generic type
with the same generic type so the three
of them they don't need to exist in the
templated component in order to make it
work
so
today i'm going to only talk about the
render fragment
and then future videos are going to
cover
the other two this is the
visual studio server side template from
visual studio
it's just nothing new and let's build it
and run it and as you can see
it's just the default
template
of laser server side and
let's
uh
talk about what is the purpose of having
a templated com in my opinion
template component gives the developers
the ability to provide
some sort of template to the component
itself and the component also provides
some sort of layout
right so this is more on the ui
side the functionality
is
mostly
on the consumer
side right so the consumer of the
component which is the parent of the
component are going to provide more
functionality
and
the
components of provides more layout
right so let's take a example that uses
the render fragment right so
uh the render frame fragment itself
is
uh
a
it's used as a as a type
of a parameter
right
and
this parameter
is
basically
a
when when you use it it's going to be a
wrapper
of
some html let's have an example so that
it's easier to explain to
it's easier to explain
so let's take a look look at boma right
so for beaumont to have this field
what it needs to do is to have this this
much him up so if i copy this and paste
it over to our
let's create a
component
actually let's just use it
on the counter
actually use it on the index right and
delete this
survey
control
and paste it over here
we need our
boma css
which is not in here
so
i'm going to copy this
over
to
laser four
and then
we're going to go to our host
and
copy this
and that's it
all right so we have our obama
in here
and this is going to work i believe
all right so let's go to this uh blazer
4 and refresh uh it's the home control
right so you see this right but
if we go back and we look at this
well
yeah so this is
it looks pretty good right looks pretty
neat the style is whatever what we like
but then what's what's gonna happen when
you have many views
on the form
so you you have to sorry you have to
kind of copy paste and this whole thing
right so suppose we have name is over
here so we have name
uh we have title
and we have
department
right
so for only three fields
we're coming the lines of html from line
number nine
to line number
44 so it's it's getting crowded with
just
three filled
right so what what can we do to make
this uh the number of lines of uh
html shorter
more compact
so we can actually make a component by
utilizing the render fragment
right
so let's let's do that let's create a
component and
i want to create controls folder and
create a component under the control
folder so let's go over here and go to
component
and then let's call this
build component
right
so
and then what we need
is this let's copy and paste it over
here and see how we can make it easier
so
we need to provide a name of the label
right so that means
we need a parameter
and
a public property with a string type and
that's
um
let's call that
label name
or let's just call it label okay
and uh
we also need input
to be somehow in there but this input it
cannot be inside the field component
because it may not be just an input
control it can be maybe a radio button
right so you don't know the type it's
better to be provided from outside and
here
is why we need to use a render fragment
right so we can take this out
and then we create a special parameter
we call it
uh
we call it uh
so it's going to be also a property and
this has to be render fragment
okay and today we are not going to cover
the one with the generic type
um
so and
here it's going to be called let's call
it control
okay
and what we can do here is
is that we render this
render fragment right over here
right when we do this laser framework
we'll recognize that this control is a
render fragment
therefore it's going to render
the html
that the consumer or the parent control
provides to the child control
okay
so with this
right what we can do instead of having
uh
these number lines of code we can have
it way shorter
oops sorry
uh we can go over here and we can
use our
field
actually let's import that namespace
so that you can see it
get over here and then if we enter again
you can see
we have that and then we provide a label
and
we call a name right we do the three
fields
and then uh what we can do here is
is supposed to be
okay so it's the intellisense is not
working very well
so
here
we have this right
and control
inside here we can have this
input
right and placeholder
and then
we copy this
three times
and this is gonna be
title
right title
and this is the part
right and look
we completed the three fields
with only
about a little more than 10 lines of
html okay so let's delete all of these
we don't need them anymore
and
let's
go back
oh
all right so we forgot to change
oh we forgot to add the type label here
so
uh
let's
label
all right going back
refresh
okay cool so we have this all right so
we just learned how to use the render
fragment
by creating a filled component
right and this field component can be
used everywhere else
whenever you want to create a field and
let's just summarize what we need to do
in order to
use the render fragment so that the
developer can provide a template
for your component to use
right so it's actually pretty easy you
create a component
right
and you create a special parameter that
the the type of the parameter is render
fragment
and then use this
in the html markup place where you want
to render that template
and then when you use it
as a child component from a parent
component
you just
declare it as html and then use that
render fragment parameter
as a
html
instead of use it as a parameter like
label you use it as html
right and then within that wrapper
with the render fragment provide you
actual html
then blazer is going to
render this
html
inside
here to replace
the render for recommended parameter
i want to cover the second key factor of
the templated component which is the
generic
typed list of items
the purpose of this items is to provide
a list of items
for the
generic type render fragment to use
but is that the only purpose can it be
used
for any other purposes
today we're going to talk about
using the generic typed items
by itself
uh we're going to learn that by creating
a
automatic rendered grid let's call it
auto grid the way i do it is that i'm
not going to have the render fragment
i'm only going to have this items and
then i'm going to use reflection to
create a automatically generated grade
okay let's jump into the
all right so let's create a
control
uh component
let's call it
grade
automatic automatic grid
all right so
we don't need the title first we need a
parameter
let's create this type param
right this is the type of the this is
the generic generic type
of this
this list
right and this we would call it items
so instead of
uh using the render fragment
with those items
we can
use this item by itself so how do we do
that
right so we need to use reflection
in c sharp we need to see all of the
properties of this item itself before
the
component is rendered
and
there is a event in the event lifecycle
that is called on parameter set
and
that function that method is called
when the parameters are set and before
the
components rendered so let's override
event
if
the items is not now
and items can't is greater than zero
then this is the place where we use
reflection
okay
type of item
is a reflection to
analyze what kind of parameters what
kind of properties
the item has
right and
the type of
the type has
a members method
which
is gonna give us some information
about
our
all right so this member info we need to
include we need to use the uh
system.reflection name
space
roof
and
okay so now we have this we've got the
member info and we can do this
all right so this member info has um the
information about of all of the members
gloating like constructors methods
properties
and other stuff
right so and then we can use this to
uh in our markup so in our markup we
want to render we want to render a table
right so the grid is like a table right
so
um this is like we only render the table
if the member information has inform has
value
uh
like this
and we're gonna render a table and we're
gonna call it um
uh
i'm gonna use the table
class
and let's first render the header
right
and uh it's gonna have a list of columns
and that list of columns corresponds to
the 2d properties we're going to loop
through
the list of numbers
right
you know this member has a member type
property and this in indicates whether
it's a constructor or it's a property or
it's a method
so we will only
create a column for
the members that are properties
so if
if number dot number type
equals remember type stock
see we have property field method
unless it's type and all this stuff
constructor
event so uh we will only render
if it's property
right
and
then in this case we render
number dot
name
and we're going to use it in our index
the home page here we need to create
some data to it
all right
so
i have prepared some data so we have
this first we declare a class it can be
any class and then um
i'm going to override
the
uninitialized
event circle
and
weather
and in here we're going to initialize
that
actually we're gonna have a
uh
list
right
and then in here we're gonna create a
list of employees
let's just call it employees okay
initialize this list employees so we
have this list of employees
and we want to provide this
to the great component
okay because we already have this items
in
others parameter inside the grid
component so now
we are going to call the grid auto
component and we know that there is a
parameter that is items
and we are going to provide employees
list to it
and let's see when we run it
what it looks like
okay so we see this id name title
department right
and uh
now we go back
to our grid component and complete the
rest of the markup so in the in the body
we're gonna get the value of of each
each property
right so in here
we are gonna say you know uh for each
item in stock items
okay so it's gonna have as many rows as
the number of items
um
so we're going to create a row under
here
and then we're going to loop through
the
basically the same thing we're going to
loop through
the properties
and then we got the
value of each property
right so in here instead of
th it's going to be td
and
we are going to call
item.type
got property
and then
which property is this property
providing the name of that property and
then there is a
uh there is another
gap
value
and um
so it's for this item
uh oh
so and i believe this is it and let's go
back and refresh
all right so we have our automatic uh
grid so this is great but i don't want
to show the id
right i don't want to show certain
columns so
what do i do
okay so we can create some
create another
property here
parameter here and let's call it
let's call it
you know
columns
to
exclude
and it's going to be a csv
and
how do we use this
so if this contains
so i guess
it's going to be in here and then i'm
going to say that
if it's a property
and
if the name
uh
sorry no it's not it's the other way
around
and
if
the columns
contains if it doesn't contain
and it's going to be
case insensitive
and
negation
so if it doesn't contain
the
columns to exclude
then
we're going to render it right so the
same logic
would be
also
applied to here
right
and
going back to our
place
then we can provide that extra parameter
that columns
to exclude and and call it id
right
and in this case i think it's going to
work let's refresh all right so we don't
have the id column
and if we don't want the name column
uh well that's probably not a good idea
let's see we don't want the department
column
we can add the department column and
then we refresh you notice the
department column is going to be gone
all right cool
and i like the department column so
let's put it back another thing is that
uh we are using boma
right and for bulma table it has
different kinds of uh
classes to modify the
uh the appearance
so let's do a search
bulma
table
and
go to boma
and you can see that it has different
modifiers right so
it's bordered is striped so how do we
giving the developer the ability to add
these modifiers
so that's an easy job we go to here and
actually we're going to have another
parameter
and
let's call it
it's going to be string type and let's
call it css
plus
right and
we are going to come over here
and i'm going to modify this to
dynamically create the classes here
so
um
so css
plus actually
let's use this
uh it's going to be
a table right so that's the basic thing
and then we are going to have
a
desktop
okay okay
it's gonna be like this
and css plus
if we don't provide anything uh i hope
it's still work all right so we're not
providing anything it still works so
let's make it
uh strapped
let's go over here
and then we add another
let's call it cs
class and we add the is
strap
over here and see whether that works
refresh the screen again right so as the
uh
the modifiers to it all right what else
we can add we can add is bordered right
it's narrow
uh it's horrible that's this is
interesting
let's add this
and
you know add this over here and
go back and refresh
cool see i'm hovering my mouse over
the rose and it's highlighting it we
have learned
one of the purpose of having
the generic typed
uh list of items
right we can use reflection
to
create a
grade automatically
and uh if yeah i think you can
i would i would see myself
use this kind of grade uh
pretty often
uh in those cases that i don't care
about providing some specific control
over
the look and feel of each
column
and if you care about that then
in my next video we're going to create a
another
grade that is not automatic
and allows the developer to provide a
template for each column if you just
need to simply display the list of
information in a
grade like this so you can basically
have this automatic generated great
component and use it in a lot of
different places
you can even provide another parameter
for the developer to use to provide the
list of names of the columns because
sometimes you don't want to use the
variable name um
yeah so that's uh that's it for today
that we learned
how to one of the ways to use the
generic typed list items by creating a
automatic generated grid
the most common usage of this
is to use this
templated component as a repeater and
there's actually another way to use it
i'm going to cover both ways and let's
start with the repeater concept so let's
imagine you have a list of customers
you want to render this list of camera
customers
repeatedly following a custom template
and if we try to write a kind of element
out it may look like this
so
you want to feed the customers to the
repeater component
like this
and then
within this you want to repeatedly
render each customer and you want to
provide a template for each customer and
that template can look in your own way
so let's say you want the customers
company name first
and then with the indentation
you want the customer
contact name
and after that you want to see the
customers phone number
and obviously this is a template
and
this
template is going to be repeatedly
rendered as many times as the number of
the customers
in the list
so
um
laser templated component
provide us a convenient way to do this
and let's jump into video studio and
look at how we would render
this kind of how we would create this
kind of component
in laser so i have
a
so this project i just created
it's uh a web assembly
project
it would be very similar to create the
same thing
in bleeder server side but this time
let's try web assembly
let's create a new folder let's call it
controls
as url
i like to call components controls the
none page component controls
and let's create a
component and just call it repeater
first the generic type to temporary
components it needs to
have a parameter that holds the data
so let's create a parameter first
to host the data
and that data is of a generic type and
it's a list right so it is a generic
type and let's
and let's call this t item
and
that
we call it
items
and this you see it's giving an error
because we need to
actually
say typo parameter
is
t item and this will make the error go
away
it's a generic type meaning that you can
pass in whatever type you want
so
generic in c-sharp is actually a
convenient way to
use type as a parameter so we want to
render the items
one by one so we need to do a loop
okay
so we'll say
item in the items
and
here we want to render the template that
the user provided so we need to provide
a template parameter
so create a parameter again
and then here is a render fragment but
it's not this
render fragment without the
the type so it has to be this one was
the generic type and
it's what's the generic type t item that
we used just now and then here
we give it a name so let's call this the
the row
right because we are rendering the
one by one as we're running rows of of
uh
of something
so here
we can say
sorry at
row
but
we can't just do this it's not going to
render the item we have to use it sort
of like a function and we provide
the item here
we feed the item here we're telling the
uh the row template
that this is the item that we're dealing
with right now
and then at the moment we use it
let's say i want to use it here
we are going to import the namespace
first
controls
so once we have it
uh we go into the index
component and let's delete this
add some
line bricks
and then
here we're going to use the repeater
component
and
notice that it has a items
parameter here
but
we are going to create
uh
some data here so i have prepared
something let's so we have the customer
here
and then let's initialize it from uh
from the i initialized
let's override the initialize method and
then so now we have a list of customers
and we populated the values of the
customers
and we can provide the items here
so
then we need to provide the row template
so when we go over here we can say
row
and uh
like we just did
and
in here
we wanted to
use customer company name customer
contact name custom phone number and the
way to do it is to say hey we are
in the context of the current customer
right so we give it a contact name
and then
here we are going to implement exactly
the same thing as
as we
planned we want to have
the company name and then some
indentations and with the contact name
and phone number like this
but we want an indentation and uh we are
using the default template comes with
bootstrap css
so we can add the
left margin so it's margin left is let's
add
five
make a little bit bigger
so that it's noticeable
and um
yeah so we have phone number contact
name phone number company and that's i
believe that's what we planned
and
let's
build this project
the the web assembly you have to build
it
i don't see a way to just refresh
as in server side later
so let's refresh
and then let's go here and you see the
companies are
sorry the customers are rendered like we
planned and let's give it a little bit
uh clearer uh formatting
so let's have a line break between each
customer and let's
highlight the name of the company so
that we can see a
better
format
and
you see if i just refresh it would not
pick up the changes
and if i build it
it will so this is the difference one of
the differences between
uh blader side server side blazer and uh
client-side blazer so now i pick up all
of the changes that i have
this is the the first weight is the main
way to use a generic type the
templated component
and usually a repeater also comes with a
header and a footer right and uh i would
implement that as well
so that
we would have a render fragment without
the
generic type
and we'll call it header
and i would have another one here let me
call the footer
and if you want to put something
as a header or footer you can use it
and in our case let's
use the header
today
um
and in the header i just want to let's
say we just give it a title this h2 and
let's say
this is customers
and render this
right over here
you see because
we are giving the user
the control of the template so
we don't want to add a div
anything around this header or in
between because that will interfere with
the user's
control
so now i have the customer right here
and have all of this
and if you want we can add some margin
over here as well but in this case i'm
going to skip that so the second way
using the uh generic type parameter is
uh it's actually it's actually pretty
interesting that if you look at the
documentation from microsoft
right here it only talks about a way how
to use it as a repeater
right you basically repeatedly render
the
item in the item list
but there is a way to to render a form
use it by using the generic type
parameter uh today i'm going to show
how to
uh use that to create a kind of an added
form template
to edit each one of these
uh customer and to do that
let's
create another parameter
and that parameter is a t item you see
this becomes interesting because the
documentation doesn't mention anything
if you use the t item it has to be a
list right but
we are
going to come to this interesting part
of it
by declaring a parameter without a list
so we have a t item here and then we're
going to say
an item to edit so this is the item for
editing only and then we're going to
provide another
render fragment
that that we can use this item to add it
um that is going to be
a render fragment
it was a generic type and yes it is the
same generic type
so and let's call this edit
template
and
you can
usually we display a edit
form in a
uh in a dialog
like a model dialog
but in this case i'm just going to
display right under the uh the feature
because we have a footer i forgot a
runner and filter so let's display a
right and there we'll have a line break
so display this form right under here so
we're going to say edit
template
right but then again because it's a
generic type you have to use it as a
method and
so what are we going to provide here so
we have to declare we sorry we already
declared this so i'm going to provide
this as a parameter here
so basically we tell them later that we
are rendering this
we are rendering this um
edit template sorry this this render
fragment right over here
and the data we're gonna use
is the item to edit
right
and then when we use it basically we
have to provide this item to edit
with the item that we want to edit in
our case of the customer that we want to
add it
so
to do that we want to change our temp to
provide a um an edit button and that
will go
under the first step
and we're going to provide we're going
to write a space here
and then
button
and uh since we're using
we are using uh
we'll just call it a button
we're using the stripe so using the
strip class
and then um
and then we call it edit
okay
and
the event handler of editing
we are going to say add we're going to
say
edit with a parameter
and that
i'm going to say add it
um
and what edit the um
add in the customer
right because we have the contacts here
so we are editing this current customer
right um
let's just call it a customer and then
we're gonna
we're gonna create this
method right here
private
so this is the customer we over here we
have to pass this customer to
the repeaters added to
item to add edit so in order to do that
we have to reference our component so we
create a reference right here it's a
reference and we just call it repeater
simple and clear
and
declare that right over here as well
repeater
and this is our customer we're going
with this customer right so provide this
and repeater
and
we call the repeater right over here we
say when we add it we want the item to
edit
um
to be the current customer we are trying
to add it
and then i
believe we're going to see an error here
yes
why because
it says component parameter
should not be set outside its component
right so what we have to do is we have
to remove this
attribute right so um we are
having this over here and we are having
this over here we don't want to display
the template unless we
uh we're trying to add it right we're in
the add-in mode so we have just have a
logic here we're going to say this dot
item to edit
only when it's
not
now
do we
do we display this added template plate
implemented edit template like this
and uh we are going to display
we're going to have
let's say
name i'll make it simple and i just use
an input
whereas a class so it's bootstrap is
form control
okay and uh we're going to bind it to
uh yeah we're going to specify a context
right here so the context is
the current
customer
and then
i'm going to call it the current
call the current customer and then
specify the property to bind to
and uh
and come over here
and make sure this is
assigned correctly
and then we build it
and let's refresh
all right so let's click on
first customer yep this time we see the
um company name
so
so uh in the future one of the future
videos i'm going to talk about lifecycle
and uh
here
we are seeing that
we are actually triggering the event
from um the parent component and usually
um
it and also
we notice that this item to edit was
defined
was defined not as a parameter so
usually changing the public property
that is not a parameter outside of the
component will not actually trigger a
rerender but in this case it did and the
reason
being is that one of the reasons one of
the ways to trigger a rerender of a
component is is a event right handling
event
although this event is handled outside
of that component
right the repeater component
but
because
you see this advantage triggered right
here right right over here on click
event and this button
this button also is it's defined outside
of the repeater component but because
it's provided as a template
so that is considered that is actually
rendered by the repeater component and
so any event handling
for this
button is also um
considered as a
um
like its own event handling that's the
repeater components on event handling
therefore when you uh trigger this event
it automatically render the repeater
component
so i'm going to talk about more about
that um about the lifecycle in future
reviews
so yeah so let's let's take a look at
this
and uh we have a form and if we have a
dialog then we can display this in a
dialog and any changes
uh is actually applied right there right
so we can change the name you can change
a phone
number right there and
you know
and
and it actually works and then you can
you can click on different things so the
company and everything changes and if
you come back you see the changes
actually retained
so yeah this is very interesting way to
use the template component
if you're more creative
then you can actually take advantage of
this very well
so the second way using the
generic type parameter is
is actually it's actually pretty
interesting that if you look at the
documentation from microsoft right here
it only talks about the way how to use
it as a repeater
right you basically repeatedly render
the
item in the item list
but there is a way to to render a form
use it by using the generic type
parameter uh today i'm going to show
how to
uh use that to create a kind of added
form
template
to edit each one of these
uh customer and to do that
let's
create another parameter
and that parameter is a t item you see
this becomes interesting because the
documentation doesn't mention anything
if you use the t item it has to be a
list
right but we are
going to come to this interesting part
of it
by declaring a parameter without a list
so we have a t item here and then we're
going to say
item to edit so this is the item for
editing only and then we're going to
provide another
render fragment
that that we can use this item to add it
um that is going to be
a render fragment
with a generic type and yes it is the
same generic type
um
so and uh let's call this
added
template
and um
you can
usually we display a edit
form in a uh in a dialog
like a model dialog
but in this case i'm just going to
display right under the uh the feature
because we have a footer i forgot a
runner and filter so let's display right
and we'll have a line break so display
this form right under here so we're
going to say edit
template
right but then again because it's a
generic type you have to use it as a
method and so what are we going to
provide here so we have to declare we
sorry we already declared this so i'm
going to provide this as a parameter
here
so basically we tell them later that we
are rendering this
we are rendering this
edit template sorry this this render
fragment right over here
and the data we're going to use
is the item to
edit right
and then when we use it basically we
have to provide this item to edit
with the item that we want to edit in
our case the customer that we want to
add it
so to do that we want to change our
template to provide a
um an edit button and that
will go
under the first step
and we're going to provide we're going
to write a space here
and then
button
and
since we're using
we are using
or we'll just call it a button
we're using the stripe so using the
strip class
and then um
and then we call it edit
okay and
the event handler of editing
we are going to say add we're going to
say
edit with a parameter
all right
and that
i'm going to say add it
um
and then what edit the um
add in the customer right because we
have the contacts here so we are editing
this current customer
right um
let's just call it a customer and then
we're gonna
we're gonna create this
method right here
private
void
and then we're editing what we're adding
a customer
so this is the customer we over here we
have to pass this customer
to the repeaters added to
item to add edit so in order to do that
we have to reference our component so we
create a reference right here as a
reference and we just call it repeater
simple and clear and um
declare that right over here as well
repeater
and this is our customer we don't know
this customer right so provide this
and repeater
and we call the repeater
right over here we say when we add it we
want the item to edit
to be the current customer we are trying
to add it
and then i
believe we're going to see an error here
yes
why because it says component parameter
should not be set outside its component
right so what we have to do is we have
to remove this
attribute right so um we are
having this over here and we are having
this over here we don't want to display
the template unless we
uh we're trying to add it right we're in
the edit mode so we have just have a
logic here we're going to say let's
start item to edit
only when it's
not
now
do we
do we display this added template plate
implemented edit template like this
and uh we are going to display
and we're going to have
let's say
okay and uh
we're going to bind it to
uh yeah i'm going to specify a context
right here so the context is
the current
customer
and then
i'm going to call it the current
call the current customer and then
specify the property to bind to
and
and come over here and make sure this is
assigned correctly
and then we build it
and let's refresh
all right so let's click on first
customer yep this time we see the
um company name
so
so uh in the future one of the future
videos i'm going to talk about lifecycle
and uh
here we are seeing that
we are actually triggering the event
from um the parent component and usually
um
it and also
we noticed that this item to edit was
defined
was defined not as a parameter so
usually changing the public property
that is not a parameter outside of the
component will not actually trigger a
rerender but in this case it did and the
reason being is that one of the reasons
one of the ways to trigger a rerender of
a component is is a event right handling
event
although this event is handled outside
of that component
right the repeater component
but
because
you see this advantage trigger right
here right right over here on click
event and this button this button also
is it's defined outside of the repeater
component but because it's provided as a
template
so that is considered that is actually
rendered
by the repeater component and so any
event handling
for this
button is also um
considered as a
um
like its own event handling that's the
repeater components on event handling
therefore when you
trigger this event it automatically
render the repeater component
so we're going to talk about more about
that
about the lifecycle in future reviews
so yeah so let's let's take a look at
this
and uh we have a form and if we have a
dialog then we can display this in a
dialog and any changes
uh is actually applied right there right
so you can change the name can change a
phone number
right there and
you know
and uh
and it actually works and then you can
you can click on different things that's
company and everything changes and if
you come back you see the changes
actually retained
so yeah this is very interesting way to
use the template component
if you're more creative
then you can actually take advantage of
this very well
blazer components are stateful component
and if we don't have a good
understanding of the components
lifecycle as developers of our mind can
be confused
and we don't know where to put the logic
that we want to implement
today i want to cover one of the core
concept of component lifecycle which is
uh you know when do a components render
components actually render under four
conditions components render
when components are just created
or when components events are triggered
or when components parameter values are
changed
or when developers manually
trigger the rendering of the components
so let's cover uh them one by one first
one is when components are just created
all right so so let's uh let's take a
look at video studio so this is uh this
is the project that i just created with
uh with blazer web assembly
and uh let's see the first one is
uh the components renders when it's just
created
right so it's this one is easy right the
reason
uh it's obvious that when a component is
created you want to render the component
otherwise like what's the what's it's a
ui component right so it needs to be
displayed
so but when
um when is component actually created
right so the components are created when
you
uh just load the component for the first
time
or when you
navigate away
and it'll get back
right or you try to refresh the page and
the components are recreated
so let's um let's see whether that's uh
those three things that i said it's true
or not so let's uh let's take a look at
the counter component okay um let's see
if we override
after
render method
and
if we
run this
so we pressed alt shift d
and so this is this is page as
we see
right
and we're using chrome so we just copy
this
all right ctrl c
and then we
we use uh windows r see it's writing
right here
so windows r
and
paste that in and then click on ok
so we'll open another browser so this is
actually the browser that we need to use
to in order to debug
so from here we do ctrl shift
d again
and this is the window that is launched
so from here we can actually set
breakpoint so go to the files folder
and then
we can see all of the even the program
files right
so we can
go to our counter component and see
whether this is rendered um
but debugging this is pretty tricky so
if we just uh refresh this counter page
you can see that
uh the
it's the trick the
the breakpoint is not actually triggered
so yeah it doesn't actually trigger the
breakpoint for the first time when the
components just created
so in order to debug go to our code and
then we can just write console
dot
red line
and this is uh this is very similar to
console.log in javascript
and then
we save it and we we build it so once we
build it we come back to this
uh
developer
tool
and
we
go over here refresh it and come back to
the developer tool if we look at the
file
uh the file is actually changed as you
can see let's refresh again
and then we go to the console and you
can see that on counter component on
developer render is rendered at this
time
so now we know that the
when the component is just created the
component is rendered
right because this event is wrongly
triggered after it renders so this kind
of proves that the event is just uh
it's just rendered another possibility
is that if we never get away
okay
and we never never get back
then
see the breakpoint is also triggered and
uh it's first render is true meaning
that it's just rendered
uh it's just created therefore it's
rendered
right so those three conditions
first one is when you just come to the
page
second one is when you refresh the page
third one is when you navigate away from
the component or from the page and come
back to that page that contains a
component then the components are
created therefore it's rendered
the second one is the component renders
when the components events are triggered
so for example in this counter component
some people think that this current
count only when the current account
changes do the components actually does
the component re-render but that's not
actually true so let's actually
comment out this line and then rebuild
the
application
and
once that's done let's go back to here
and uh let's
refresh the page
right
once we refresh the page
we can actually go to the source code
and we can see that the counter
component
actually
doesn't have that
see this is the color component so this
is already common out right so this line
will not actually run
at all
so
what we can do here is that if we click
on it see these uh i'll render
after render event is also
triggered
so this proves that
as long as there is an event
that is triggered
then the component is re-rendered
right and you can see that this
parameter is false meaning that this is
not the first time this is not the
components just created this component
already created and we clicked on a
button and that button does nothing but
the component is still re-rendered so
that's the first point i want to um
i want to emphasize here
the second point is that
the
when events are triggered that's true
but it's not every single type of event
it has to be
uh it has to be a ui event like clicking
a button change your drop down list that
sort of thing has to be a ui event
so let's do a demonstration
uh that what if we are increasing the
account the counter count by a timer
right so if we come to the application
and we
if we
add a timer here
so basically we create a timer that runs
every two seconds
right 2000 millisecond and then it
triggers the increment count function to
increment the
current card value
and
let's run it and see what happens so
let's refresh the page
so it picks up that and uh you can see
that the current card is not actually
increasing
but if we go to the page here
we go to the console we can see that the
counter value is being actually being
increased every two seconds
right
but
this event is not a ui event therefore
it's not
rendering the
re-rendering the component
even though the variables value is
actually being changed and if we click
on it you can see it's 18. why it's 18
because it's 18 right here
right it's 18 right here that's when it
rendered because we clicked on that and
that's a ui event that's why it has this
so that's that one
as long as not a ui event it cannot for
example if if you have an event in a
child component or in a parent component
and you're implementing
um
a matter that uh
registered to that event and when the
event is fired uh from the parent of the
child components
and and
you you have a function within this
component to be called
and uh even when there's values there's
variables that are being changed
and that even when that variable is
actually being used on the ui
your component will not be rendered
re-rendered just because not a ui event
right so similar to the
timer event
so another point i want to emphasize
when the component ui events are
triggered uh the
components re-render that's usually the
case but that ui event has to happen
within the component
right it cannot happen outside the
component and hype outside the component
that's um it's not going to be rendered
so for example if you have a parent
component the parent component has a
button and if you click a button click
on that button in the parent component
the child component will not be
re-rendered right and if you have a
child component that has a button you
click on that button the parent
component cannot be rendered will not be
rendered
and we can do a demonstration
but let's let's stop this timer so i
want to create a component right here
okay we can see the component is
rendered
and if you go to the other developer
tool you can see that the conjugate
component render and the child component
also rendered the child component
rendered after the the color component
render after the parent component render
but if we come over here and click on
the
click me button
and we go over here you can see the
counter component is rendered again
right but it's not actually triggering a
re-rendering of the child component the
child component is not being rendered so
if i'm going to click on this a few more
times
right i can see it's all about the
counter component the child component is
not rendered
right
and uh the same thing will happen again
if we try if you try it if you put a
button under the compo under the child
component
and uh
you're gonna see that the child
component renders let's actually do that
let's go to the con
the child component
and let's put a
button right here
and
let's have a method
all right
and we refresh
and we come to the
window clean it up click on click me
you will see the child component
actually rendered
i also click on a few times
three more times you can see
so the important thing to notice here is
that
you although the event handler here is
not doing anything you have to have a
event handler in order for the component
to re-render
right although it doesn't do anything
and also another thing you notice that
they the
uh rendering is only the component the
child component renders the parent
component actually does not render
right
so
and uh but there's only one exception so
this this is the point that i want to
emphasize that the event has to uh
trigger from inside the component only
when the event that is triggered inside
the component that's that same component
gets re-rendered
so um but there's only one exception
when you use a templated component
right so let's say that
we have a
template
so i have covered the
templated components a couple of videos
couple of episodes ago
so if you are not familiar with template
components please go back and and look
at my previous videos
and refresh
we see this click body template and
let's clear the uh
console and we click on the
body template
i click on once and we see that
the color component that's render and
child component also gets rendered
right
so if i click on two more times one two
go here you can see that both counter
component and child component gets
rendered
get rendered
so why is that uh well the reason is
that the
the body template
is kind of special that when you
have buttons
uh or html elements within the uh body
template or template within a template
it's also considered part of
the child component
right it's considered so this
button is considered part of this
component so when you click on the
button it's as if you're clicking a
button within that child component right
it's actually part of that
it's actually within it but because the
fact that it is also part of the
it's also defined right in the parent
component
so that's why the parent component is
also rendered
okay okay so that's the second uh bigger
topic here
you know
the components re-render when the
components events are triggered so i
covered
uh the three important thing i want to
emphasize again so events
uh
we don't need
variables to be changed as long as you
have an event handler
for event
even the event handler you do nothing
about it the components also gets
re-rendered right the second important
point is that the ui it has to be the
event has to be a ui event
any other events like a timer time
defense or a uh
event delegate you register to a to
event delegate within some other
components and that the events get
triggered within this component this
component will not be re-rendered when
the event happens
the third thing that i wanted to
emphasize is that the event has to be
triggered from outside sorry from inside
the component
not outside the component
except
for one case that if you have templated
components then that template
the but the the event happens within the
template triggers both the parent and
the child component
so okay so now let's uh move on to the
third thing which is the
uh component parameter values changed
but this this is a simple one uh
if we go over here and uh
we got a component
and if we
create another parameter
and that parameter would be
the counter
if we just display the contour value
right here
so
let's encounter
and
from the parent component if we feed
that
counter value right here with the
current
account
then every time you um
every time you click on the uh the
button
every time you click on
this button
the click need button
um your child component also gets gets
re-rendered
right so without
so let's delete everything that is
distracting
and we don't need this
either
i
don't need the template component
we don't have this and uh
we don't need this
rebuild it so uh here if i click on it
you can see that
the color value does not change so weird
because we are not passing it and
and uh if i click on it again you can
see that the only thing that changes
because we render is the
component which is the parent component
but if we can go to here go to the
parent component and if we pass that
parameter
right over here to be the current
account and if we build this
we refresh the page
and
well we click on it we can see that
all of them
suppose
both the parent component and the child
components get re-rendered every time we
click on it right
so you can see
both are
re-rendered
so that's the third and the fourth
condition is when developers manually
trigger the rendering so again if we
remove this and if we just come over
here and even we remove this
and
if um
from here if we reference the child
component
let's say child
and then
over here say private
component
um
child
all right so this is that component and
uh if we just uh every time
we do this we say child that will
contour
current account
if we do this
let's see what happens
so basically we are increasing
the counter value
of this property
right it's not a parameter
but
we're not expecting that this value
would change so
you can see that it's not changing right
although the value is gets uh increased
the only reason why it's not changing is
because the child components not render
rendering that's because none of our
four conditions are
right we're not doing any of these so
the child components is not being
re-rendered
um so in order to re-run it
we have to as developer we can manually
trigger that rewriter
we can have a public
uh
method callery render
this stage refresh
and we call it
we call it and then when we come over
here we can call child
dot refresh and that will trigger
the re-rendering of the cal component
and let's go over here
refresh the page to pay to pick up the
change and let's do this you can see
that
both the
counter component and the component and
the child component pick up the change
and if we go over here we can see that
the uh
we can see both
are re-rendering
okay so that's everything i uh
want to cover today remember there are
only four conditions that the components
get re-rendered
first is that when components are
created first second one is when
components events are triggered third
one is when components parameter values
are changed third one is when developers
manually trigger the re-rendering
so i'm going to cover the
sequence of each one of the lifecycle
event
in terms of in what sequence they are
being triggered so i'm going to cover
both the server-side laser as well as
the webassembly blazer i'm going to
divide this into two categories the
first one is the first time rendering
right and the second one is
after the first time
so the first time rendering is when the
page is just loaded
or when you navigate to the component to
this page component let's first cover
the first category
with server side laser
so i have server type laser default
template
i have all of the
events
written down and i break break points
same with the shot component i have all
of the events i have the breakpoints for
each one of them and i have the child
component
used by the parent component so i'm
going to run debug
and let's pay attention to
uh
in which sequence these events are
triggered again this is a server side
blazer right so the set parameter is
async in the parent component it's
trigger first
and then
i'm going to hit continue
and on initialized second
on parameter third
and when i press
continue again
now i'm expected to go to the child
component
instead of carrying off
so
i
have five
and the side parameter is async in the
child components ahead
and secondly the
initialize the trigger and the child
component
followed by our parameter set
so if i press continue again it's
actually not going to
go to the shoot render or after render
same with
in the parent component these two events
are not triggered so let's go over here
this is where our breakpoint is
currently at so i'm going to hit
continue again
now
we're jumping back to the parent
component
and again the same parameters async is
rendered and our initialize and then
so i'll initialize and then press
continue again on parameter set and then
actually when i
when i come when i click on continue
it's going to jump
over here again
and then on the slide and then practice
that
so
why are they
rendered
uh
twice
these three events are rendered twice
that's because if you look at the
diagram
we look at the diagram we have the
browser and we have the server side
the first request sent by the user and
then the first rendering is
so this is ser again this is server side
blazer okay server server type
the browser sends requests first and
then renders for the first time
including the
the javascript
for server type laser and that's
javascript establish a signal r
connection and then server set renders
the component again
that's why i render twice
that's why those three
events are called
twice right so after this watch what
happens if i continue from here so i
jump back to the parent component and
cause the um on
after render
skipping they should render because this
is the first time and it has to render
it doesn't make any sense to allow the
developer to to control whether to
render the component or not it has to
render the component and then i continue
jumping to the
uh child component calling the on after
render
event handler again
and if i continue now the page is
rendered
uh i when i first asked that the
the double rendering only happens when
the application when the component is
loaded for the very first time
so if you never get away
from the component and then navigate
back because the signal r channel is
already established
so
those three events that are
called twice
will not be cut twice again so let's
demonstrate that so let me
so let me refresh the page
okay so we notice that we're on the
parent component
three events
child component these three events going
back to the first
parent page these three events
and secondly
on the child component
so we notice so far
these three events are called twice both
the parent component and the child
component that's because i refresh the
page
by refreshing the page the signal arc
connection is re-established that's why
these three events are being called
twice and then we're going to the on
after
render
on parent page
parent component and uh unlock to render
our child component
right so if i'm not doing that if i
never get away from the
uh
from the home component from the index
component
navigate back to the
index component watch what happens now
okay these three events
and then truck component these three
events happen again but then
those three events are not going to be
called a
cut twice so we're actually moving on to
unlock surrender from the parent
component and then i'll have to render
for the shot component okay let's
summarize so the one sequence that we
are experiencing in server type later in
the first category which is the first
time rendering is that the
these three
events are being called
uh one by one in the parent
component
and then the same
set of events are being called in the
same sequence in the child component
and then after that the same thing
happens again right
for the parent and for the child and
only after that
the parent component after and there is
called and child component after ender
is called seeing this
any initialization code that you put
inside these three methods
uh on server type laser is gonna be
called twice
so
when you're initializing your
data
you have to really pay attention to
where you put unilateral initialization
there is a on after render
async
with a parameter that indicates whether
it's the first time or not so for server
type laser i recommend that you use that
to initialize your data
in the on after render depends on
whether you are
going to use that data to render on the
screen or not
if yes then you need to call this state
exchange method to re-render the
page again now let's look at the same
thing in laser
web assembly because it does not
actually trigger the breakpoint
uh so you can either debug it
through the browser
uh which i have demonstrated in the
uh
previous episodes so today i'm going to
actually use console.write that is
similar to
the
console.log in javascript so you can
just do this and then expect to see
expect to see the the log is written in
the console window in the developer tool
so i'm just going to do that all right
let's go to blazer let's go to developer
tool and we can see that uh it's
actually the same sequence right parent
component called this three uh three
events
trial components again this is three
events and then parent components called
unlock to render child component calls
unlock to render
the only difference is that
the only difference is that the parent
component
these
three methods are only caught once
because this is web assembly
thus
the second rendering is no longer needed
because there's no signalr channel that
is
this is that is established
now let's moving on to the second
category
which means re-rendering
right and from the previous episode that
we know there are four different
cases that would trigger a real render
let's
use a button
i have a button here
and i have invite handler here so this
is server type later so i have a
breakpoint up right here and let's run
it and see what happens if i click on
the click me button here the first event
that is called is actually the event
handler of this button
right
and then after that so we are on the
parent page the button is only on the
parent page current component so click
on the continue button
we're calling the shoot render and then
if i click on it again
we're calling on the i'll
unlock to render and notice that we're
still on the parent component and you
see that the
child component re-rendering is not
called if you watched my previous
episode that you know the reason why the
child component is not re-rendered right
so those none of those four conditions
satisfy so the child component are
not going to be re-rendered whereas for
the second category which is the
re-render category
uh this let's summarize that it actually
looks like this right so first you have
your parent component
and if there's no condition for the
child component to render
what you're going to see is something
like this
right you have your parent component
shoot render and then your parent
component after render
and if there's parameter change or any
other condition that triggered the
render of the truck component what
you're going to see is something like
this you're going to have your parent
component should render and then these
three events and then parent component
after enter and then child component
afterwards something that is interesting
i want to uh point out is the true
should render okay so let's do a
let's change this to return
false
now let's see what happens so i'm going
to click on the queen
button and then the event handler of the
buttons are called first
going to shoot render
and then
you see that the count is now changed
and
so that means the child component is not
re-rendered and the parent components
are actually not re-rendered we did not
go
normal over here didn't see the
breakpoint of this
render and it's called so it wasn't
rather so for the the second category
which is a great render scenario uh the
server side and
the
the up later like the web something
blazer are exactly the same so i'm not
actually going to run the demo again
i want to go over a pitfall in data
initialization in blazer components
so i have a parent component which is
index component and an employee detail
component right here right the parent
component is
using the
employee detail component to display the
details of the
employee and the employee is initialized
or loaded in the parent component and
i'm hardcoding the employee here to
mimic the situation that we're loading
this con this
employee
and each employee
actually has a bunch of records to be
loaded uh
once we go into the
employee detail component this
employee is the records of the employee
is loaded
so
we look at this code we have
uninitialized here in the child
component and also all initialized here
in the parent component and we run this
there's going to be no problem
right
so let's demonstrate that as you can see
the homepage just loaded was the
employee detail there's no problem
nothing is wrong with this
but it actually has a potential issue
what if this
employee is loaded
slowly
there's some kind of network slowness or
a lot of data needs to be loaded
so let's use the sleep method to
mimic that
scenario
so let's go back and refresh the page
okay still no problem when we never get
away and then we get back
uh it takes five seconds right four
five
right so five five seconds to load it
but there's no problem
okay but but the potential problem is
that sometimes you you have to load
these in asynchronous version of the
initialization or
in some other
lifecycle events right so instead of
using the
um
the synchronous version you may have to
use the asynchronous version so let's
demonstrate that so
instead of using this if i use this kind
of code here
right
and then if we use this asynchronous
version here as well
then
let's
refresh the page all right there's no
problem if we
never get back still no problem right
that's because this is actually called
first right and then they all initialize
methods in the child component called
secondly afterwards so what if we add
that
sleep
uh thread back right so what if we have
a method like this
in our parent component we're using
we're using awaytask.1 to mimic a
asynchronous call and then
we use the sleep five for five seconds
to make a long running process here
and let's refresh the page and see what
happens in this case right so
it's throwing suction complaining about
the object references now which happens
in this place
the employee is now when the low records
is being called so that's through the
exception how should we deal with this
kind of situation
right i would suggest that
that we first uh
we need to call
we always check whether the object that
we're trying to do with is null or not
now we need to do the null check now
reference check and then also
instead of using our initialize we
should use i suggest that we use on-prem
intercept because it's always called
when parameters change
and then inside here we have to check
the reference as well because we don't
want to load the records over and over
again right whenever there is a change
unless that's something that you intend
to do
so in this case we will see that
if we refresh the page then it's going
to be fine except that it takes five
seconds one
two
three
four
five
right let me get away and then we go
back
two
three
four five
traditionally we're using this regular
forms for user to input data
and if we look at the contents of this
we have a formal element and then we
have input field and then a submit
button
so when user clicks on the submit button
the forms will be posted back to the
backend
to this location but application written
with blader is a single page application
which means only the first
page load
goes through the http request and
response pipeline
the subsequent actions will not be posed
back to the back end
in order to still perform
forum submissions microsoft came up with
a set of components
to perform the task so instead of using
regular forms in blazer we should use
the edit form component
instead of using the regular input we
should use
input text input number input date input
select etc don't worry about the
error here i'll fix this error later
when the
submit button is clicked event handler
specified which is valid form submitted
and if you want to handle
invalid form submitted
so then you would do on invalid form
submitted and
connect it to a function
right so here's
two things we need to know
first we need to use a added form
instead of a regular form and then we
use
input first differently
another thing we need to know is in
order to handle the submission
we specify the method
the next thing we need to know is that
the edit form has to be bound to a model
i declared a lot of class here person
and then i slide the person right here
and then
in other form
there is a parameter
that is called modem and i provide that
person model
instance to this model
and
next
i need to use bind value to the data
binding
and i'm associating
each
properties
inside the person class
to the input
elements the next thing we need to know
is validations in order to
validate the model we can use
data annotations we need to first
use that name space
and then we can
annotate
the properties
which
the annotation attributes like required
string lengths
max lens
range
we can specify the data type like email
address
etc
in order to trigger the validation and
display the validation messages at the
top we need to use
the data animation
validator
component
and also
we need to put validation summary here
and that's all we need to do
for a basic validation scenario
okay so let's run this form
and see what happens right so if i don't
do anything
i click on submit button
it will give me the required error
messages
if i put -1 here
and click on this it would give me the
range error message
and emails is also still required
if i put
abc dot abc
so let's put this
then it will directly say that email
address is invalid
so if i provide a
correct email address format
then this becomes green
and if i give it a correct number
then all everything is green
okay and the submission will trigger
the
uh um
will trigger the unviolent summat event
and this event handler will be triggered
okay so that's the basic of validation
uh i just wanted to before i finish this
episode i wanted to
mention
a couple of things notice that this v is
a capital v
so
usually when you use
a data binding outside of
added form
you would use a lowercase v
and if you keep using the lowercase v
you will encounter very weird errors
so remember to use capital b here
another thing is that if you put buttons
here
like this
the button's default type is going to be
a submit button
okay so if you put buttons here
expecting it behaving like a regular
button
it's not going to happen it's going to
work like a submit button
so if you want extra buttons
to work just like a button then you have
to specify it as a button
first i will quickly go over what
dependency injection is so it will have
two modules or two classes
one is higher the other is lower and
higher one depends on the lower class
for example the customer service class
needs to use the functionality of the
customer
data access class
right
in order to get
data from database
then we say that customer service has a
dependency
upon customer and data access in order
for the higher
module to use the functionality of the
lower model you know we have different
ways to do it
right the first obvious way
is to
have an instance
of this customer class
right over here
right
and then we'll just call it customer da
right and then in our
constructor
say custom da equals new
customer
that access
you know with a problem with the
connection stream
from somewhere
right
and then you can use it
to
for example get a customer
get customers
right and then
here
we can just say customer
return customer dot got customers
and that's
actually you'll have a
numeral
right so we get a list of customers like
this
so this is uh one way to
make the
uh
to make use of the functionality of the
our module
but as you can see that
the customer services uh is uh tightly
coupled with customer data access it is
aware of the definition of this class
and
there are many different
problem problems with this for example
if you want to have different teams work
on higher level optic
one team work on higher level module the
other team work on lower level module
because this um
tight coupling
it's very it's very difficult to work in
parallel
right and also
if we were to change this
the name of this class then you have to
go to change
uh
all of the codes over here right you got
to change you're going to change this
you're going to change this so uh and
you you need to
recompile the higher modules in order to
do that change right so the
maintainability is is not good right and
later and
if we
want to uh so if this dead access layer
is going against a file system
right and later you want to create
another class
all right
that's going
against
uh going as a database right single
database
for example like this
right then
you would have you would have to
go inside and change to change the code
right so that's extendability is also
not good so there's many different uh
this is a disadvantage of doing this
kind of tight coupling
so
there's this uh dependency inversion
principle which says higher level
modules should not be dependent on the
lower level models
both should be dependent on abstraction
so what is the abstraction abstraction
is
because the dependency there is the
dependency between the service class and
the data access class right so
that dependence cannot be removed
instead what we need to do is to
abstract that dependency and that
dependency is the functionality right so
dependency is the functionality and we
need to abstract that functionality and
in c sharp the way to access uh to
abstract that functionality is to use
interface so we can create an interface
like this
and then we can say i customer data
access
and
in there we can just say
you know
all we want to do is to have
a
is to get a list of customers this is
the abstraction right so basically it
just says i have a way
to
get customers
then whoever implements this interface
we'll have to implement notice that this
method doesn't have a body right it
doesn't have an implementation so
whoever actually implements this
interface
okay they need to
they need to have this uh this thing
implemented
so
right here we need to implement this
in the concrete class
right i'm not going to implement
anything i'm just going to do this
right so
uh in this way
we are not actually using
the concrete class here we're just doing
this and that um takes the dependency
away but again it's still having the
same problem we're actually creating
this instance of this concrete class
right here means that the higher level
object
is still
aware of the lower level object so how
do we do that we have to
take this responsibility away
from from the customer service and this
responsibility is is the instantiation
responsibility and we need to take that
away and this is called inversion of
control right but don't worry about that
and how do we do that
we need to um create it from outside
right the simplest way is just to you
know just to create it from outside
like this the a let's use a different
variable name
right and again you can just do it this
way and then um
when this
class is instantiated
or we can just uh
just do it like this
then
we're going to say da because da and
that's it right so our
private instance has this and then when
from outside we can when we instantiate
this class
then
then we can
just say
you know
pass this
into it
so that's these are the main two steps
first we need to use the abstraction
which is the interface in c sharp right
secondly instead of
directly instantiating the
concrete implementation of the interface
we use constructor
and then
pass that instance from outside into
here so this is the dependency injection
in c-sharp and it's the same concept in
every other languages
of course there are different ways to do
it this is through this instructor you
can also create a property
of that and then
just
just say
if we were to create a property instead
of
doing like this we can just say
have our constructor stay right here
and then we can just say
you
public
i so in that case we don't need this
all right we can say i customer data
access and then we can say
your customer data
data access equals
uh
well let's use this name because it is
set so this is the property in c sharp
and then when you
use it like this you can just say
instead of
doing like
this you can just screen this and then
from here cust
service and then you can say
custom data access
close
data access
and then and then you can use it in
other methods
so that's dependency injection in
general and then next let's go
into video studio and see how dependency
really works in blazer components
let's see how dependency is injected
into laser components
first let's look at servers app laser
let's
create a
class let's call it customer service
this customer service will have a
public method
that returns
a customer
and for that let's first create a
customer class as well and that's it
let's keep it simple
and
in here
we will return the customer
will say get customer
by id
and the parameter
is an integer which is the id
okay
so create a
constructor
and this constructor let's initialize a
list of customers
and then in here
okay so we have this service
and uh
we want to inject it into blazer
components
and let's inject into the index
component which is a page component
that has
a routing path here right let's delete
this
survey prompt
and
let's display let's use this in our gold
okay
so one way to do it
is to
declare
a
customer service
and then
we'll just say customer
service
equals new customer service
okay so this is not this is this has
this dependency problem that is that
that is making the index component
tightly coupled with
the customer service
class but that's not we that's not what
we want to do right so we have learned
what dependency injection really is the
two main steps first is that we need to
use interface
so that our index component is dependent
on interface so we need to do is to
create an interface okay
give it an interface
because i customer service
right um there's only one behavior
right here which is
getting the customer buy id right so we
copy that
and paste it over here
and that's it
that's the
uh once again must declare a body oh
okay
yep
so this is abstraction
so it doesn't need a body
and then go over here we just use our
customer service
right so we have already implemented
the
abstraction
and uh
the second step is to inject
right so first we need to register into
the container which
blazer is based on asp.net core and
asp.net core there's uh
to in order to
register the
services classes service classes
into
the container we can use configure
services
okay so we can
we can register right here but there are
actually three different
lifetime scopes right
um
there's
singleton there's scoped
and there's also transit
okay so first let's examine transient
giving the pair of the interface as well
as the implementation
all right
and then when we ask for it
we go to our component
where we want to use the customer
service and we just say
right inject customer service
right and then right over here
um
we can just uh we can just declare a
private
customer
customer this is our model class so it's
okay to be dependent on our model class
right
so and then
in the
override let's overwrite
all right i just just want to set a
breakpoint
just so that
i can show you
when this component is disposed
okay so i'm going to debug so if i move
away
you can see
when i move away
it actually
just poses
right when we move back
it creates again
we move away
it is poses
and it will move back it grades okay
and if you pay attention to these
numbers right seven six seven when i
move away
let's
remove the breakpoints
and move back
number changed from seven seven six
seven to one b7
right
you can see every time i do this
the number changes and the reason every
time i move away you can see the
disposed method
and never get away from the index
component
you can see the disposed method that's
called because the index component
corresponds to this home page
right
so
uh this dispo dispose method gets called
which means that every time i move move
away this component is actually
destroyed
right and when i come back this
component is created whenever it's
created this dependency injection
injects the method sorry injects the
class to our component
then we can use it here
right so this is and every time it
changes and this is the behavioral
transit transit says that
i register a service to a container and
every time i ask for an instance
the container will
create a new instance of that class and
inject that into our component
right into where we want to use it
so that's
what we call transit and if we want to
see what scope means
let's actually see what singleton is
first
all right so let's
change this
singleton
and this time i'm actually going to use
control f5
to debug it
also
so that i can run it without debugging
actually i'm not debugging it
all right so you can see that we have
this number here
and if i move away and move back you see
the number does not change
so that's singleton singleton means
there's only one single
instance of the object
the custom survey object
in the container
throughout the lifetime of the this
application
right
even when you refresh
which actually resets the connection
you can see
the number does not change and that's
the behavior of singleton singleton
there's only one instance and if we want
to look at how
sculpt means
how scope works
let's change this to
scoped
all right and then
let's come over here refresh this screen
because we used control five so this
hot reload works
so let's refresh it and see the number
change right and then
but if we never get away and never get
back you can see the
number still the same
it doesn't
change
so it seems like it's a single 10 but
it's not
so if i refresh which
uh by refreshing this it disconnects the
connection and re-establish the signalr
connection
right because this is a blazer
server-side
so
so then
the connection is broken and
reestablished
so you can see
this time the number changed after i've
refreshed
and that tells us that
the scoped
lifetime configuration
makes the service
live as long as
the connection
okay so as soon as
as long as the connection does not
get disconnected you will always have
one instance you have to choose the the
best suitable
lifetime configuration
for your services class
right because some of them you want to
use trends and some of them you want to
use scoped
for better performance or for whatever
reason
and sometimes you want to use singleton
right
for example
you don't if you want to use some
classes to contain some data and
try to use uh
try to implement
state management that way
and
you don't want to use singleton because
that way you are
sharing the data across all of the users
even users from different browser
sessions from different part of the
world are going to see the same data
unless that's your purpose
so
for state management that's very
specific to particular user
you can use scoped and that's
that's related to that one particular
connection which cannot be shared
between different browsers
right but for very light services you
want to probably use transient
right for uh
services that is not threat safe
which means concurrency doesn't work for
example
the db context from entity framework
you don't want to use
singleton you don't want to use scope
even for transient it's created every
single time
it may still have problems so you really
want to consider the different
services
and different scenarios
so this is blazer server side so next
let's look at laser
laser web assembly
we're going to have another instance of
register 2019 and then we'll click on
placer app
this time
we don't see that startup file that's uh
this is webassembly so it doesn't
actually have it and you can see that
they are registered right here so we can
do a similar thing and we can say
builder
dot services dot app transit
so
we're gonna say customer
service okay so we don't have this
namespace as well
so we have our
customer eye customer service
providers
to it
so basically we're just saying that
uh for this interface this class
implements the interface
and then we ask for instance of this
interface
uh the container the built-in container
is actually going to create an instance
for us
by instantiating this customer service
right
and what we want to do here is uh
same thing we're going to do
do it within here
where we will
inject
our
customer service
over here
then
we are
adding this we're actually going to copy
this code from
uh right over here
here we register trending
all right so let's run it
ctrl 5 again so we have this running
and you can see
the number is ce2d and when we move away
number change go away number changed
again if we refresh number change
all right refresh again
never change it again
all right
so
uh so this is trended right so basically
it's the same thing as later server side
where
every time the component's class is
substantiated
a new instance is substantiated and
injected into the component okay so
that's that one and then singleton
actually basically works the same way
okay which is
also you know every time you ask for it
you're gonna have the same instance
all right so refreshing
downloading that again so you can see
that it's c97 and if i move away move
back c97 when i refresh
see that this works differently now
the refresh actually changes uh changes
changes the number
see every time i refresh i get a
different number so i explain this a
little bit uh
later
but we just take a look at the
scope
and
i build again
and then come over here and refresh
downloading the whole thing nine four
nine
when the movie move back
is the same
right it's the same number but when i
refresh
it also changes
so it looks like the singleton
and the scope
are working exactly the same way
right only trending works differently
and the reason for that this because
this is web assembly so the whole
server set code is actually downloaded
all of the dlls are downloaded to
the
client side in the inside the browser
and inside there we have this um
webassembly context and all of them are
actually hosted within that context
right
so which basically means that's program
this console application here
this console application here is
actually running
uh inside the browser that's why when
every time you refresh it
it creates a new instance of this
program
right because this program
is the cost application is basically
destroyed
and then this it's recreated
and the main method is run again and
that's why you see
the even with singleton
it's
it gets different number different ids
every time you refresh the browser
right and the scoped
because there's no connection and
there's no requests
so
a blazer
webassembly doesn't actually have a
scoped
uh lifetime management configuration
it's
if your scope is gonna work the same way
as singleton
all right so that's um
everything i want to cover for today
uh there's a one last piece about uh
dependence injection blazer which is uh
which is about uh configuring owning
components
and that one is
probably
not so you don't use it so often so i'm
not going to cover
in this video
you can
go ahead and read the documentation
the components in blazer are stateful
and with stateful components on the
front end you will very soon run into
problems
with uh state management and that's why
uh they're different architectures from
managing this state and one of them is
flux
from facebook
today we're going to look at what flux
is
and how we can implement it in c sharp
and using in our laser components
all right so let's get started
so with a component whether it's a laser
component or angular or
ugs or react
it does not matter
what's the component
uh
there's always gonna be a view
right
and then you know the user will interact
with the view
and then
uh
that interaction triggers some events
and events are handled events are
handled
and then
handling the events will mutate
the state
and then when the state is mutated
the view is updated
so you're in this in this
triangle
but the problem is if we only have one
component
a very simple project
and we're maintaining the state
in components themselves within
components themselves that's not a
problem
but once you start writing more
complicated code
um
doing more complicated projects
you may run into situations where you
have to share the state within different
components
that's where we need to
extract that com state outside of the
component put it somewhere else in what
we call a state store and it's more look
like this
so we have a state store
where
the state is
stored
and then we have different components
okay and will be the same kind of
triangle
right
because the the user will interact with
the views it will trigger some events
events are high note and mutate the
state
right and then the view is notified and
updated but in this case it's slightly
slightly different in style
when the status muted file is mutated
uh
the notification
is not only sent
to
one component
it will be sent to multiple
components in this case you can see that
notification is sent to
this component one as well as component
two so the same thing will happen if the
user interacts with component two
then
events are handled and
state unified and then notification sent
to both components and update both
right so this is all good and this is uh
this is actually what we call a observer
pattern
okay so observer pattern you have you
have subject
and then you have observers
right
so the subject in this case is going to
be our
store stick store
and the observers in this case are our
components the observers actually listen
to this to the subject of interest
to the store
and then as soon as there's anything
changed in the subject
the
observers
will get notified it's more like a you
know push notification
um on your cell phone
cell phone apps and whenever there's a
change you receive a push notification
right but you have a choice to to react
to it so this is all good and works
pretty well but
when your project get more complicated
you will run into situations where one
user interaction was the component we'll
need to
mutate space in multiple stores that's
where
the dispatcher comes into play right for
example
you you're building this
messenger app you have you have a whole
bunch of friends on your left
right and then you have your uh user
you have your user
component so this is going to be your
friend's component on the left your user
component on the top and then your
message components in the middle
but what's happening here is that what
if
i log out
right so i log out and that
that message has to be sent to most
components
right so you would have a
user
store here
and then
a fret store here
and then your message store here three
different state stores but when you want
to log out
right that message is to be sent to to
both of these stores actually all of the
stores right so you would want to
sent to all of these stores
so that's when
we need a dispatcher right that's when
the dispatcher come into play
so dispatcher
works like this so same
workflow the user interacts with the
view to view trigger some events events
are handled and some actions are
dispatched are sent to the dispatcher
dispatcher is
is going to dispatch the actions to
different stores right and then the
stores will mutate the states and the
states will update the component again
right update the view if you compare
this with the original store with only
one store
this is nothing more than a two level
observer pattern so you would have your
store as a subject
and
your components as observers
the second level of
observer pattern is your store
as observers and your dispatcher
has subject
stores observes
dispatcher as well
and you may notice that there are
actions being passed around those are
messages right and the reason why we
need
is because
a dispatcher
dispatches
all kinds of different messages and we
need to distinguish the differences
between the messages
right
because
they may maybe for different purposes
so that's why we have this action
message object here being passed around
another thing to notice that these
actions are like messages right and
these actions
when the dispatcher dispatches the
actions
to all the stores that are registered to
the dispatcher the stores can make
decisions to ignore it or not just like
you can ignore your post your push
notifications on your cell phone so to
simplify this architecture the flux
architecture flow actually looks like
this where the user
interacts with component the component
send a notification action to the
dispatcher the dispatcher dispatches the
action to the store the store handles
the action and mutate the state
and and then send a notification
to notify the component that the state
has changed
then the view is updated
so
normally
the facebook team presents the
flux architecture flow like this
and i think the reason why they put
action here is that they actually put
methods within action instead of using
it
as a pure
model as a pure message
and that's confuses me a lot so i i
change it so that the action is
only
working as a
message
and so when i implement it i implement
as a pure model
so
let's jump into video studio and try to
implement it
first let's create a blazer app
doesn't matter doesn't matter which one
we should create
let's use player server app
all right
so we have this
later server app created
and
if we run this ctrl f5
we see the default
default blader app
has this contour we're going to change
this counter page
to use a
a store instead of a local state
so if you look at the counter page right
now the counter component
it has a
it has a local state
right and this local state is referenced
in here in the markup here
and uh
the
increment
the click click me button calls this
increment method
to increment
the count and then it's displayed here
so
what if we want this display not only in
this place
what what if we want to display the
counts not only in this um
in this place but we also want to
display right here
right
so
we need the state to be centralized
somewhere
and that's
when we want to introduce the store
so we have we may have multiple stores
so let's create a
store
folder
let's call it stores
so that you know it may have multiple
stores
and uh let's
create a
another folder
do we need another folder
yeah
because we may have different actions
right so let's create a
counter store
folder
and
for now let's just create a
class
and let's call it calendar store
and that counter store it needs to have
a state
okay so let's implement a class
that
represents that state
let's call it counter state
and then in here we just need a variable
that has a
integer type
right so
uh
so
we want to so we would want to have
integer type
count
and
i don't want it to have a setter
so let's initialize this in a
constructor instructor
right that's it so we have this that
only has a scatter
so that our state is immutable
which is which is better than mutable
this is we're actually
using that in the central place
and
in our store
we'll have to use the counter state
right
so we'll
um
use our encounter state
like this
well let's just call it state doesn't
matter
what state it is
so our counter state here and then
we'll expose a
gas state method
all right so
we'll get the counter state
expose this method
so we return this state
and
here comes the
um
the observer pattern we have to
implement that you know we have we have
to have a listener so i'm going to put
this kind of
you know code right here right
underneath here so we'll have a private
member
which is a listener right
listeners right we have this action that
kind of like an event handler but
we use action so that it doesn't have
actual parameters
uh so i have this private action
listeners
and then i need to implement a
ad
like
register the listeners right so
we're actually
you know
we call it a state change listener
right because
it's listening to the store for stick
change
okay so let's call it this way
and
we're adding the listener
and uh what we do is that we just say
listener
then
we have another method for removing
the listener
and that's when we do this
um
and then whenever it started to change
in this state our store will block us
that change
okay so we need a method to broadcast
that change
we come over here
yeah so instead of using this local
state
into dependency in jack the connor store
right so if we go to our
startup class computer services
and
just add scoped
okay so
because we don't want to share the state
with all of the users
scoped is scope to the connection
right so we can have our store
uh connoisseur
it's called corner store
right here
we're not implementing interface
just yet
so
adding this one instance
associated with that connection so as
long as the connection is not broken it
will be the same instance
of this kind of store
and that's good enough
so in here we just say
inject
counter store
oh
let's actually
import this
so we don't want to see
right there so i've got namespace
imported
and then just
leave this
so we'll have this counter store
on the store
so this corner store um
right here so we can delete this
and then
you can go over here and say
current store
dot state
dot gas state
dot
count
right
and then
uh our kind of store will also
also so let's actually use a region here
because this is
boilerplate code i want to see it all
the time
so this is
listeners
well actually let's call it observer
pattern
observer
okay so
let's close this
and
we're going to implement increment
okay and then
increment the count
and then we'll create another
current state
all right because it's uh immutable so i
had to create a new one
and then we'll call
broadcast
we call broadcast change
the same thing will be
same kind of implementation for
decrement
um
and then all the differences right here
okay
so then
um
increment count here we'll say
you know on her
store dot
increment
this broadcast thing i wanted to be now
i
wanted to be proud
so uh increment
and
then we have to register
our
component to listen to the store right
so for that we'll override
initializer
just
automatically formatting things in a
weird way
so
over here we would say
we're going to store
counter
store
dot register um
add
stay change listeners
and
you know we would just
add an inline
arrow function
um
i just say you know whenever there's a
change i want to call this stage changed
in the third
right
so we have an increment and then we
station that's it
i'm not going to implement
the i dispose
interface and to dispose that
so
just because i'm doing this for
demonstration purpose
and because we want to also display that
in the menu so go to the shared folder
to find the menu navigation menu where
there is a counter right so in here we
also want to inject
and
we all let's copy over this
code from here so
i'm going to the manual and
okay so we have this
and
so we'll listen to the change
right so we register this and
we add a listener
so that
the
nap menu component will become another
observer
to observe the state changing the
counter store
and
right over here we'll add a colon and
then
we'll say
under
store.gastate.com
okay and let's go ahead and look at our
page
refresh our page
no reference
okay so the problem is right here we
forgot to initialize the state and to do
that
we will come over here and say
okay the constructor and then
we'll say
state
counter
state
and
zero
right so the initial value is zero
and then
control five
all right so we have our counter number
displayed right here and here and if i
click on it it increases both places
right so our observer pattern works
so that's the first step
what if we want to
do some change and in fact multiple
stores that's when we want to use
dispatcher right so we don't have to use
this pattern
um in simpler situations like this
you know it's it's okay to just use the
store observer pattern right there right
but if we do want to use
the dispatcher then we can implement the
dispatcher we have implemented the conor
store
with the observer pattern and that works
pretty well
and next i'm going to implement the
dispatcher so that we have the two two
level
observer pattern to implement flux
the flax architecture is nothing
but just two level of observer pattern
okay i've implemented the
at the first level which is this one
okay and i'm going to implement the
second level of the observer pattern
all right let's jump into video studio
and work on implementation of this pack
last time i have implemented this
contour store which contains a
counter state
this conor store allow the components to
mutate the states in two different ways
one
one is increment the count the other one
is decrement account
okay so there's two methods that
corresponds to that
and also it allows the counters allows
the components to register
and the register
from the store right so basically listen
to this store or remove the listener
right so add listener and remove
listener
and uh
if we go to our counter component this
is
from the initialize method
we are
adding the listeners
right and then we're using
the magazine injection inject the comma
store
into our
component and we're using counter store
gas state
dot com to display the code and from our
navigation menu
navigation manual we're also dependency
injected kind of store and display in
that store and when we we are
incrementing decrement we can see the
color change
uh and changes in two different places
one is
on the navigation menu right here the
other one is in the counter component
right and that works very well so today
i'm going to continue implementing the
dispatcher
okay so let's go back to
our store
and before i continue to implement the
dispatcher i want to point out one thing
sorry let's go to our counter component
i want to point one thing before i
continue working on the dispatcher which
is this uh
ad listener
i have to remove state change listeners
there but i didn't use it and um
and in my previous video i said this is
i said that this is a demo so i'm not
going to implement that but i want to
emphasize that this is very very
important because the connor store is
a dependency independence injected into
our components and connor store is added
as a scope
right uh
a scope which is scoped to the
connection right this is blazer this is
a server-side laser so a scope is a
scope to the connection so if you don't
refresh your page the kind of store
what will live as long as the connection
so unless you click on the refresh
button
then that's you know this is recreated
so that means that because
we
registered to the counter store
essentially we make the component has
the same lifespan as the store which is
a scope
right as long as the connection so when
you navigate away
later's framework's supposed to dispose
it but it cannot dispose it because the
store holds a reference to the component
so it cannot
dispose it and when you
when you come back to the counter
component it will recreate and create
another instance of this so because it
cannot dispose it
when you never get away and never get
back and never get away but it will
create multiple instances with the same
component
right it will never
uh
release that will never cl recollect
that so this is a memory leak that we
have to do with so in order to do that i
want to emphasize that that we have to
do with that and the way to do that is
we need to implement
the i disposable
interface and then
inside of our code block we need to
implement the dispose
method where we have to say your counter
store
remove
remove what so instead of using the
inline arrow function
so
if we use
private void update do right
and in here we're going to call this
state change
okay and then
instead of doing this we just
just put update view here and
when we remove
we also remove the view
so
so this is it this
when the component is disposed this
dispose method will be called and then
it will deregister the listener right so
detach the content from the counter
store
which in turn allows garbage collector
to collect the
the instance of the counter
counter component all right so let's get
started with implementing this pattern
so in order to implement a dispatcher we
first we need to you know this pattern
dispatches the actions so we first have
to implement the actions
so the actions um that's
the different kind of actions right so
first will be increase
like increment action
so add a class
command
action
all right and
in there
we can
declare a
constant
which
we can call it
increment
or
let's just call it increment
all right and then
create a moment
uh
but remember that we're going to have a
decrement actually we have all kinds of
different actions
but this pattern should be able to
dispatch all kinds of different actions
so for that we need to use poly
polymorphism and
we can use interface so we're going to
have a i action
interface
and
and for that we will
go outside here
we'll add another uh interface here we
say called i action
and the action has to be able to
identify itself
about you know what kind of action it is
so that our store is able to
distinguish what kind of actions is in
decide whether the store will handle the
action or not right so for that we need
to
um
uh
we need to have a read only property
just to get the
name
of that
the action
so we can have that
have it like this and so
so um
we're going to implement the interface
right so
we have this and then
we're going to say is we just
we just return increment and that's it
all right so and and we're going to copy
this
and change the strip decrement because
we are going to demonstrate two actions
right um increment and decrement
action
and then come over here we call it
uh
decrement action and then here
again i want to mention that the reason
why we use classes
as actions instead of just use a string
or constant or enumeration
is that sometimes
action will not only carry the
information about the name of that
action to identify what type of action
it is but also carry some
useful information like functional
information in it for example
if we were to allow our user to set the
count of the counter directly instead of
just incremental decrement we need to
allow the user to input a number
right and when we
create a
set number action
that actually need to contain that
number the user input
in that case having a class like this
right and then input a
sorry implement a
no property
like this
well it's going to be a number right
like this
will help us to
transfer that information from
the component to the dispatcher and from
dispatcher dispatch to different
components that subscribe to this
spectrum so that's the reason why we
need classes
and another thing about the good thing
about classes is that you can see all of
the actions
that the
particular store
has to handle
so so now we have two actions and let's
go ahead and implement this pattern okay
this pattern should be outside of the
store so i'm gonna add a class right
here and
let's call it
action dispatcher
action dispatcher
so action dispatcher
will will allow
different stores to subscribe to it
right so
remember this is a publish subscribe
pattern which is also called observer
pattern right so first we need
a
you know we need action
and
we just call it
registered
action handlers
right and then we're going to have a
public
method register
right we register basically
or maybe you should call it subscribe
okay
um
subscribe
so we're passing an action which is
delegate right um
passing the
action handler
and
we're gonna
call register action handlers
we do
we attach the handler
and that's it and
and another one will be the
and
action handler as well and only thing
that is different is
doing this
and of course we need our it's actually
very simple
we need our dispatch method
which will be called
by our component dispatch different
actions
so
we'll just do this and then here we're
just saying already store if it exists
then
we invoke and pass in the action all
right to simplify this
we can
include this
magic wand
symmetric one thing and this expression
body right and we do the same thing here
it will make it look
way simpler same thing will make look
simpler but remember this dispatcher
right it has to be called by all kinds
of components so we need to do
dependency injection in order to do the
dependency injection we need to have a
interface
and we don't have to do it line by line
so we can just
go to edit and then go to refactor and
then
select extract interface right
right here we can also just do ctrl r
i
right ctrl r ctrl i so this will so i
action dispatcher
and we're going to create a new file
and
we are going to have
uh all three methods to be included
all right so let me implement that and
the i action dispatcher is right here
and that's exactly what we need
okay now we need to go to startup
and
right over here and we don't want to do
a single 10 right here because if we do
a singleton then
the action will be dispatched to
different users
we want to be scoped to the
the connection so we call it you can
still use scoped and then we are going
to use i
action
dispatcher
okay and
associate that with
the concrete implementation
and that's it
for uh dependence injection
configuration
so now we have the action dispatcher we
have implemented the the action the
actions which are the increment and
decrement action
now what we need to do is
we need to use it
in our store because our store
need to be able to handle those actions
right
so
we will
depend is inject
first we need to dependency inject
dispatcher
with dispatcher and
control
dot
will select the
second one
okay so i have this that actually
dispatcher action dispatcher
so this is
right here and it put it right inside
our observer pattern here and i don't
want it to be here
so
i will put it
up here
actually i'll put it up there
and then
so i have a dispatcher and what we need
to do is that we need to
register
to the dispatcher so what we can do is
actually dispatcher dot register
actually subscribe
right
and
we need to subscribe we can put in our
action handler and where is our extra
action android we don't have it yet
so
so
right under done under here we can
create the action
uh
the handler
which
can be a
uh
private
method and no actions and
we need to be able to pass in different
kinds of actions
right that's why we need action
and
and
then we can subscribe we can pass into
this
so this is the um
action handler right
in here
so in here we're also facing the same
question are we going to call and
subscribe here
okay so are we going to implement the
destructor
right the finalizer
that
so i'm sorry
are we gonna do this
counter store and uh
i'm gonna say
desktop action dispatcher
dot unsubscribe
window
actions
are we gonna do this uh i would say we
don't need to because
they both scope to the same
actual same connection right
so they have the same lifespan
so when one is collected the other one
is also gone
so
in order to simplify our goals i'm not
going to implement that
so here
we are going to handle different kinds
of actions and we have a choice to not
handle every
not handle every action because
dispatcher is going to dispatch all
kinds of actions to all kinds of
components that are
subscribed to the dispatcher right so
all
components the subscriptive dispatcher
will need to determine whether the
action is something that
that they want to handle so
because every action has a name
right so we can use that so in here we
can say
increment action remember it has a
constant so we can do this
and then decrement
if it's a decrement action
decrement
action then it also has
has its name
action dot name
so
we can
uh
in here what we need to do is that we're
gonna call the increment account
that we implemented last time right and
then
here we're going to call decrement
and
this can become private
so
so we registered
right we subscribed here and then we're
handling the actions right here
and now we need to go to our counter
because you're going to see problems
here that this is private
so
in order to fix this problem so we are
not actually
directly calling this method anymore
we are going to
independently project
our
eyes pattern
action dispatcher
so
we call it action
actually this
patchy
and then in this increment here we're
going to dispatch
a action and what that action is it's
going to be the increment action
and that's it
so
this
uh because this is
um
in the memory it's centralized and this
will publish this action to all the
stores in the store well currently we
only have one store to deal with this
uh 12 stores and the store will
will determine that we're going to
handle it or not in our counter store
yes we're handling both the increment
and decrement okay so this right here we
will still keep it right here because
uh this remember we are two level of
we have two levels of observer patterns
so this
is to
attach listeners to the store in order
to get notified when the state changes
so this we have to keep right here the
only thing we need to change is this
action dispatcher thing so instead of
calling the store directly we're
dispatching this action
through the action dispatcher
and to
that will actually publish the actions
to all of the stores that subscribe to
the action dispatcher
right
so
let's give that a try so i'm gonna do
control f5 running the application right
here yeah that works
okay so this is
uh how i implemented the dispatcher you
can implement in different ways
another thing you can do is
you can have this
action dispatcher action interface and i
action dispatcher you can extract this
into a class library and use it in
different kinds of projects
and
you can even
implement a store
state store base
and in there
you kind of subscribe to the action
dispatcher
and when you implement a stage store you
can just
inherit from state store base
so that you don't have to do this
subscription
all the time
in this section we're going to talk
about authentication in server-side
laser first let's have an overview of a
typical authentication system and see
what are the components in a typical
authentication system so that we know
what we are going to configure
because to configure authentication for
sp.net core there's many
components
so
having a
big picture
will help us to understand what we are
actually configuring
right so there's three basically there
are three different layers
of any authentication system so we'll
have the ui layer which will interact
with the users to register
login recover password
manage user profile etc
and then we'll have the
core functionality for authentication
which is to authenticate and to
authorize
right so this is where we
receive the user information and
we authenticate the user information or
authorizing from information right so we
will have a
ticket either ticket or token to deal
with
and then we verify the ticket and see
whether it's valid that's the
authentication and then we'll see
whether the user has
sufficient permission to
access the resources the user is trying
to access so that's the authorization so
it fails for authentication then it will
return http 401 which is unauthorized
right and if it
fails to
offer fails on authorization then it
will um return http 4 3 which is
forbidden
and last but not least
this is the db or the rm or the db and
rm
combination
that's where the
user information the rows information
and everything else the claims are
stored
and
the data is
and operated
right like saved or updated
or deleted
so those are the main
parts of a typical authentication system
so now let's look at
how we gonna configure them
first let's create a server setup blazer
application
and let's select later server site and
let's change authentication to
individual user accounts and store it
under user accounts in app
right we're now going to
cover the cloud scenario and then let's
click on create so
then let's first take a look at the
project file
so remember we have three parts the ui
the functionality as far as the database
okay so for
database
this is the package okay this is the new
get package that we're using which is
the rm
which in this case is led framework core
okay
and uh
for
functionality
we're using identity framework
right so this is the identity for led
framework core
so this handles the authentication and
authorization
and for the ui so this is the package
that contains all of the default user
interfaces
that handles login logout register
and all those other
user interfaces
okay and then let's look at the startup
file and see how these
different packages are configured
right how those three different layers
are configured
so we have configure services and
configure so configure services
are configuring those basically the
packages right and the configure
method is actually configuring for
office configuring the
middleware
right so again
we're going to look at our you know
database or rm configuration which
happens right here on the top
right so this configures
our
entity framework
and it's
it uses this connection stream which
comes from
this app settings
right so this is
our connection stream
this is our database and then
uh the second one this is configuring
the functionality this is configuring
our
identity framework
right
and
also
providing a identity user model this
model corresponds to the spdat user
table in our database
okay so basically this
configures the identity framework also
connects
from here
back to the database here right and this
is providing that model that corresponds
to that and this is the the database
context which corresponds to the
database and then so basically this
configures the database this configures
the functionality so which part is
configured in the uh the ui so
there is a the ui is actually inside
the solution uh but
this authentication state provider
this is
when the ui needs information of the
current login user
that's uh
that's what this is for
all right so this gives us the user
information
then let's look at the configure method
and the configure method
uh it configures the middleware for
authentication
okay so
this
user authentication and use
authorization there are two middlewares
that handles the
authentication authorization
when these middlewares are being used it
look looks for
specific concrete implementations of
certain
interfaces like eye authentication
handler right and those interfaces are
actually implemented inside
the identity framework which we have
dependency injected by using these
these calls
so then
you're for authentication authorization
it will use
these injected classes
to to finish those works
and then last but not least
this map controllers can configures the
routing for our
default user interfaces because
we're going to see
that the
user interfaces are
not laser components right not reader
components
but
reader pages so those razer pages
need
a default routing
which is the default attribute rotting
and also
this map controllers
uh set up the
default reader page rotting which is
actually
according to the the page structures
and that's uh
now let's run this
so first we need to register user we can
use any
email doesn't matter
right and then
we're gonna give it a password
and then we register
this comes up because there isn't a
database right so we need to apply our
migration to create that data because if
we look at our data folder we can see
this migration here that actually create
all these tables the rows the users and
all of the the other ones right the role
claims
the user claims everything else right
so these tables are only
for now
models in
our c sharp code so those c sharp codes
has to be mapped to the database and
that database has to be created first by
clicking on apply
migrations
it's going to run this
these mega research migrations and the
database will be created so that's um
that's entity framework
so i'm gonna click click on apply
migrations
right okay so register confirmation so
we click here to confirm our account so
normally this is going to send an email
but here it's just a dummy one
and then
because we have already
register so we are going to
login
okay so we logged in
right now
we can access
all of these
what if we log out
can we still access all of them yeah we
can still access all of them so then how
do we secure our blazer components
okay to see you secure a specific
component for example if we want to
secure our
counter and both counter and fast data
pages then we go to the component we go
under pages go to counter
and we use
we give it attribute right so
which is um
if you're familiar with sp on an mvc or
a speedometer coordinate c or
so this is a
attribute sorry uh
the authorized attribute that you you
usually use for your controllers
so we use this here and then we copy it
to fetch data as well
so now
uh
we go back to our component refresh go
back to our
page and refresh
that's good so both counter component
and fetch data component
says not authorized so this is how we
secure our individual components
another thing we can
use is the authorized
view component
which we can the authorized view
component is a templated component
so
we can use that
to
so it has two templates which first one
is authorized
right and
second one is
not authorized
okay so these are the two templates and
if we copy all of these
actually
let's
leave the title outside
to make it more realistic
because we are not going to hide our
title
but
we are going to hide everything else
to be inside the authorized view
and then
you say you are
not
authorized
please
contact
admin
then here we can remove this
and come over here and refresh the data
refresh the page
going over here you can see you are now
authorized please contact with me go to
counter you see not authorized okay
and
so this is the this is so removing that
authorized that's important so don't use
that authorized attribute because when
you use this
it's not controlled by the authorized
view
component
right it's controlled by something else
so this using authorized view and the
authorized template as well as not
authorized template
we have covered this so if we revert
let's revert all of these
okay
and we use this so how do we provide a
global authorized view that's under the
app component so here you can see that
we have this authorized walk view which
is also a
a template component
right so here
we can give a global
information about not authorized in here
it's say you are
or you don't
have her
permission to
access the page please
contact
admin okay so if we do this
you can see that you don't have
permission to access the page please
contact me and if you go to fetch data
you see the same thing so both of these
are seeing this uh same message so this
is how you
provide
the not authorized message globally
but if you want to provide an individual
message message you can use the
authorized view like what i've just
showed
another thing
that
you typically want to do is to
utilize the user state or the user
information inside your logic so for
example under the home page if we want
to display some user information here
right so we're going to go to our uh
index component which is the home page
so i'm going to do this survey thing
and then
give some line break
and here if our logic requires
user it requires us to provide some uh
to
to utilize the user information that
comes from the authentication state so
if we go to our app component on the
root component again we can see this
cascading authentication state and this
is similar to the this is similar to
cascading value we're actually cascading
the
authentication state down to the
component tree
right so in order to use that cascading
parameter we need to declare a cascading
parameter here
so first we have this
code block
and then
we're going to declare a cascading
parameter
and
that parameter is going to be because by
default cascading parameter are mapped
to the
parent level
the root level by type right so here is
authentication state so this is the type
of
state
we're going to keep this as a product
parameter it doesn't need anywhere else
so we can use this
and then
certainly we can use this as a
in
user actions for specific logic
but
what i would do for the demonstration is
i'm going to
override the uh initialized
async and then in here
we're going to say this off state we're
going to actually await
this off state
right
okay let's change this to
underscore all state
and then here we're gonna
say
state
and
we are going to
use this
and what we're going to do is
i'm going to say if
our state
is not
it's not now
then we're going to display some uh
some information about the user
right so
let's say the username is
uh
state dot
user.identity.name
over here we're gonna flip through all
of the claims
okay let's all of that please
and we're gonna display
type
okay and i'm gonna display
um
value
all right so this is so this is how we
are going to get the
authentication state which is basically
we're using the login user information
so let's test this
we'll refresh the page we don't see
anything because we didn't log in so
let's login
uh
my password
and we don't see anything
oh okay okay
so
that's because of this
refresh
all right so we have this
username it's just basically the email
address and then we have all of these
claim type and claim
claim values
not very useful
in this case but
it could be useful in
if we ask some more meaningful claims at
least this uh
this name and the value this is more
meaningful
all right so that's how we use the
authentication state inside our
component
next one is if we were to
customize our identity
uh framework model let's first look look
at our database
okay so this is the database we're
connecting to our
local
local db right so
let's
go to server explorer
so this is going to be our database and
testing connection everything is fine
click on ok c is
the tables so we have the esp9 users
table
right
it has all these information what if we
need something else inside here let's
say we're designing a
you know a education system
or a learning system and we need a
school
information for each user
right we need to be able to store in
here so then how do we customize the
model so in order to customize the model
under here we can create a
a class i would call it sp
net
uses
users
right
and uh currently
if we look at our iterations and their
which we have seen it's using the
identity user right
so what we will do is we're gonna
inherit from
the identity user
okay
here's our
identity name space
and uh
so because we're inheriting from the
identity user so we will have all of the
existing columns
but what we need is a
new column that is called
school
right
which has a string type
so that
we next we're going to go to our
application
uh
db context in here we need to provide
our specific user type
right the user
model the corresponds to that asp.net
users database okay so we actually have
this
just created here
right so
just to be sure
f12 goes to the class that we just
created
right and next thing we need to do is
inside the startup uh instead of use the
default identity we can just uh we can
change it to use identity and change
this to
sp not users right
and then
the second parameter
identity row
and then we would add a migration
so in order to do that we're going to go
go to our
tools
new git package manager console i'm
going to say add
dash
my migration
uh we say
extended
asp
net
users
all right so build succeeded generated
the migration second version
uh in the up method we can see it added
school column we go back to the
console here
and
we're going to say
update
update database
build succeeded okay start
let's look at our server explorer and
whether the whether we ever
refresh it
do we see school yes we see school
right so we added this
so that's how we customize our model so
now let's talk about how we can
customize our user interface so if we
look at the
project structure here we can see in
areas
the errors folder which contains some
pages under account we have a logout
page
right then we have a login partial what
if we
want to customize the register page
right where do we do it how do we do it
we go to right click on the project
click on add and then here there is a
new stuff scaffolded item click on this
we choose identity select identity here
click on add now it says scaffolding
right it's trying to find inside that
you get packaged wood are actually
included inside that new gap pack here
we can see all of the user interfaces
that we can customize
so we are going to customize the
register
user interface and
so this scuffle is going to connect from
ui all the way to the database that's
why it needs to select a database
contact data context class right which
is this one that we have and then we
click on that
and then it says it's scaffolding all
right so under the areas we are going to
see a register
reader page here
right so we have this freezer page here
what if we want
a
uh
what if we want to add the school
information here
right so we're going to
go over here and if we look at our
input model which is here
email password
right confirm password what if we
need school
information here so
we're going to say
school
and
this is
school
right and on post
on post we're going to say
school
equals
input.school
so this is the information that will be
will be used later and to persist the
data into the database
so our our logout page are still using
identity user
in fact we can just search
in the whole solution
to see where our identity user stu are
and then we'll replace
all of them so inside here we have
identity user so we're gonna have to use
our identity user
okay to solve that problem uh we can
come over here
and uh
we can say
add default
ui
to go to default behavior and then
add default token providers as well
okay that should fix the problem and now
let's run
the application again
and if we register
okay so we're missing the school
field let's go to our register
raiser component let's copy this
all right so it's going to be here and
then
school
copy and paste
and that should do it let's
build
the solution again
and come over here refresh the page
we will see
so school field and let's do our tester
at
gmail.com that's tester2
okay and password is going to be our
password
and school is let's call it my school
and then click on register
okay so
i'm going over here and then
all right so we have our
uh
page
and
we're able to access all of these
um so now let's take a look at our
espy.net user table to see whether that
email is there let's run a query new
query
i don't know why the screen is flashing
like this
so let's select star as net users
and then let's run a query like this
and we have
test her too and the school is my school
right okay so we have successfully
customized our user interface to include
our new field which is the school field
and we also successfully customize the
asp.net users table
by going through the led models and add
migrations update database
i want to create a data grid component
i want my datagrid component to be very
similar to
device devexpress or dive stream data
great component at least i will have
some column configurations
i will
have the functionality of sorting and
paging and perhaps something else as
well
so in this video i'm going to cover the
column configurations
so let's get started this is a
server-side laser
default template from visual studio so
let's create the datagrid component
under the controls folder
razer component
so in order to have
the data passed in
i needed to be
to have a
generic type
and then
from there
i need to use the generic type
to have a
list of items
and let's call up data items after that
i need to define like to configure the
columns
and for that i need my columns to have
to indicate what kind of data field
within the t item
that
that we're going to use for the column
and we'll come caption
uh data type and format and alignment
as well
so let's have a
configuration folder
okay and let's create a column
definition class
so have this and what i need is
data fill
and i would need the caption as well
right because
the name of the column we know can
may be different from the caption
of that column
and then i would need the data type
so for that i would need a data type
class
right it has
nut set string number date date time
boolean currency
and
i would use it here as a data type
and after that i will have a
format and this format is i plan it to
be a free format that's why it's a
stream
and then i would have alignment as well
and for that i will create alignment
class
and that i will create here
and it's going to be an enumeration as
well
and it has not set
left center right
okay so with the column definitions
i want to have a
constructor
of this and i want to initialize
the data type
to be
set
now everything is not sad at the
beginning right
alignment not set
okay
and then let's go back to our component
and from the component
and from the component we will have a
list of columns
as parameters
so that we can define our column
and uh i need the controls
to be in here
in the import file
so the namespace is here
so i have column definition
i'll call it columns
okay
and with this i should be able to
render
a
and i'm going to use the boma
all right so i imported my bulma css
file
and uh
so with that we start uh we're gonna
start creating the html here
and for that
we will use a table because it's a great
and uh
class will be
uh full west
okay so it's a former
plus
and let's create the header first
okay uh so we'll have um
a row of header
and
if we don't have the columns
that's where we're gonna use a
reflection
to
you know
to deal with
here
we'll just uh
we will need to loop through
and here we need to create the uh th
element
right so it's going to be
um
ph
and then the column are captured
so
let's
let's test this
um let's use the
index component
and uh let's import i think we import
that already so we will have our data
grid while we don't
and that's because yeah we don't have it
yet
we have this let's import this namespace
controls
and then we go back to here
we can have our data grade
and i don't know why it's still
complaining that
uh
so
controls
and let's go back to here
and we'll data grade
degree component
and we have our
data items column definition and
everything right so let's just use it
just for now it's going to complain but
let's add this
code here
then we need to initialize the
definition and stuff okay with that um
we have i have some definitions created
for um
i have some data created
from previous videos
uh and i have extended that
so let's just copy that over
so i have an employee
class specified here
right and i need to
define a list of employees
um
in here
and initially i need to initialize that
i also need a column definition
right
and that's
that is here
and
i have my initialization
method created already
so let's copy and paste that over here
and let's take a look
what it's trying to do is it's trying to
initialize
if it's null then we create a new
definition and that of definition has
name title department employee
employment date and salary and captions
are named title department employment
date with the space
salary is
annual salary
right and then we have our employee list
hardcoded over here
just for testing the data component data
great component
so
with this
we can specify the tm
t item to be employee
right and then we can specify
our data items to use the list employees
and then we can use
we can assign the column definition to
columns
okay so with this i expect that the
component starts showing
i expect the components start showing
something
okay so we have nothing here
we have nothing here and that's
because we are not calling the
initialize method yet
so
we're going to overwrite it and we're
going to call the uninitialized
lifecycle event
so that our
list employees
sorry so that we can initialize
this
right here
right so both have column definitions
both have both
we're checking whether it's now or not
on both
attributes
so
uh
so we're using so it's okay to use it in
the uninitialized
lifecycle event because the
uninitialized left circuit un is
actually being called twice if you have
watched my previous episodes
you know this
it's going to cut twice on the first
first
page load
so
um
and
we made a change and go back and refresh
the screen all right so we have our name
title department implemented in annual
salary
so that's pretty cool and we noticed
that we have a space here and a space
here
so it's actually picking up the um
the caption and that's that's pretty
good uh so the next thing we are going
to work on is uh
we're going to display the data right
so for that since we have already
initialized data
let's go back to our data grid component
and let's
add the t-body
body element and from here
what we need to do is just simply loop
through the data items
right
and in here we have the rows
and we just need to
you know
go
also loop through the columns
and uh
provide so
inside the double loop
we use
um
reflection
t item
and then we just got property
got what property and that's where the
data field
you know the data field is being
used here right because if we go back to
column definition we can see the data
field here and if we go back to our
initialization data initialization
we can see that the
data data field
you know it corresponds to each one of
the properties in the employee class
right
so
here
so we use the reflection and provide the
data field as the name of that property
and that's that will get our
corresponding property from the employee
class
right and here we just need to get value
and get value of what value of the
current
current item
right and that should provide us with
the data and let's go
refresh the page and see whether we have
all of the
uh
data displayed here all right cool so we
have the data here
and uh we noticed something
that you know
we want to have some formatting
uh the salary is not showing dollar sign
like it's not being displayed as
currency an alignment for numbers should
be aligned to the right i want to see it
to align to the right uh i want the
employment date to only display the date
part so we have some formatting to do so
let's first
go with alignment
do with alignment and for that we
we already have the alignment in the uh
in the definition and for alignment we
have not set left center and right
and uh to use alignment we need to
do something with um
header and as well as data so let's deal
with the data since we just finished
data here
so
so inside here i think
what we need to do is um
if
if column
dot alignment
is not
not
otherwise if
there is a definition for alignment
then
well let's implement the else because
it's simply just this okay and if there
is a alignment
then we need to
have
um
we have need to have it here
so just say column dot
um
alignment
yeah alignment uh i don't know
maybe you guys can tell me why
whenever i type
uh whenever i use the intellisense the
dot goes to the
to the end of that line instead of
instead of at the at the
right place
i don't know i don't know how to resolve
that problem
i tried space i tried
uh enter i tried tap it has that problem
sometimes it has that problem
so then i go over here and i do two
string
um
and then i can do i need to make sure
it's
lower and lower case
right because
it's it's left
it's left center and right and that
corresponds to css style so i can just
use a tostring here
and
i think
that's it for alignment at least for the
data part right and let's go back and
refresh and see what happens i'm
expecting
um
the alignment to be to be right because
um
if we go back to our
definitions here you can see that i have
um
alignment to the right for salary
the salary column
right so yeah so it's working right uh
then we need to have the
um
the header to be also aligned to the to
the right
i need to go to uh the header part and
then
let's see whether
we can do the same thing um
we just
copy this
and get it over here
and
instead of
using that complicated stuff for data
yeah just remove
this say column
dot
caption
and remove this part
and let's see whether we can get the
alignment right okay so i got the
alignment right but then it changed the
changes style
right
so
i think it's uh it got rid of the um
something related to the th
because the alignment that we assigned
here
oh okay so it's td
we use td so let's go over here
and refresh again i change to th now
ah okay
so
let's inspect and see what happens
so i have it on the other window and uh
moving it over here
who has the we have the alignment to the
right but something is overriding
uh
this and that
should have something to do with the th
here
and that's
and what is that
okay so inherits
it inherits from something
okay so if i
yeah if i add it back
then
yeah then
if i remove the
inherit
then it works
so i may have to add another
class
and that's when that's where i usually
in
bootstrap or oma i create a override
class
and let's
take a look at the
and let's just create a
override style
stylesheet
so stylesheet
style
uh stylesheet and i'll just create a
let's call
okay
and uh
in here i will have uh
i want to create
a
alignment
my
style is also targeting th
and
i wanted to align to the right okay
and that would have uh
text aligned to the right and since i'm
trying to override so i'm gonna use
import important
and
since i'm doing this i'm gonna create
for left center
as well as
right
center
okay
so
and i have that and if i go back and i
just um
alignment right so here i have to do
switch statement
switch um
dot alignment
right case
column dot
alignment dot
uh
sorry
case
alignment dot
left right
and case alignment dot
center
case alignment dot
right
and uh another case
just do nothing in other case
fix this typo
and
i think the formatting is weird so let's
format it
okay
coming back up
and
so
so instead of using it right here let's
put it
inside
and
we need to use the class that we just
created
so we have class
and i will call a line
left
over here and if it's
if it's alignment
or if it's default
then we
and use should be okay
let's see what happens if we refresh our
uh
still not working
and why is that
inspecting
okay
and
we have our class here's our class
we have the align right class right
but it's not loaded
perhaps um let's go to
i think
perhaps we need to
the style sheet here
so
we have this already here
and i need my phone to be here
and
i also need
my uh
override
to be here as well
and let's see whether
this would fix that
problem okay
very cool so we have our
class correctly
applied here
next thing is
i want to have the formatting as well
and uh and for that i uh
planning to do something simple
uh if we have if we go back to our
here
um
where we define our columns if we have
our format
if we have our format see i have this
data type
as currency i have this format as well
um
and i have the format here as well so if
there is a format then
then i want to format it otherwise i'll
just leave it alone right so going back
to the data grade component and
we need to add some formatting
in the
in the tea body area
right
and that's where we will have
some kind of if statement right
so
let's say
if
the format is not empty
right or null
if column dot
format is not empty or null
and uh
f column dot data type
we also because the format is kind of
dependent on the data type
so i also want to say
if it's
if it's not
if it's
set already
then i would actually
format it
and in here i also need to do some
switch statement
according to you know different data
type
i would format it differently
so if it's
date
um
let's state
constant date
you know
state
or if it's
a um
date time
then
i would
you know what i'll create a
string here
and this is the value and if it's a date
or the type of value would be
in time dot
parse
the
because this value is basically
an object
so i would have this and then i would
call
tostring oops
oh okay so
to
stream
and then
i have
you know i have this and then i just to
string because this is a daytime and
then i use what i use the
column
dot
format
right
and that should do it so that's for
uh day two or day time
and if it's a boolean
if it's a boolean
then
we're going to do it a little bit
differently right
we're going to say value
sorry value equals
again it would be similar to the daytime
thing
we just instead of daytime we use this
we're gonna parse it and then
we're gonna
we'll just say two string
and this should give us whether it's
true or false
and
and then
if it's currency
currency
uh why there is a problem here
i don't know why okay there's no problem
so as a currency
um
i also wanna just
copy this over here and
so
i'm going to use
you know it's double
and i want to parse that value
and
this would give us
uh currency i just uh you know what i'll
just
i'll just use this
and i also want to
run it
i will use mascara and
i'll provide
this
okay
okay so i run it first and then i
convert it to currency format
so then i have the format here
and so i have sorry i have the value
here
and
so i have the volume value here and this
here there is the alignment
and i just need to put the value
so instead of
this i just need to use the value i
think
all right and that will be like this
and
yeah same thing as
here
i'll just put the value here
um what's the complaint does not exist
well it's right here okay
that value
is supposed to be
inside
here
all right so that's when it has format
and if it does not have format
oh yeah it should use the original which
i got rid of
um
yeah so let's revert
i'll copy this first
and
i'll revert
okay that's good and then i have it
right here
and else so this if statement is if
there is a format
right so
we're dealing with otherwise here
otherwise we just use the original one
which doesn't go with any format
okay so i think we're good and going
back and refresh the screen all right so
cool we have our um employment date
format we have our annual salary as well
so that's
i think that's what i want to cover for
today i covered um column definitions
column configurations i covered
uh
formatting and i covered
alignment
let's implement page for a paging
under the configuration folder i will
need a
paging configuration
class
to be able to configure paging
so create a class
and i'll call it paging config and i
think
i would
yeah let's make it simple
so i would have
enabled property
and
page size
and i would also have
let's have just
these two for now
so yeah in theory
if given a page number we need to go to
that page
right and we can do that with link query
so with was link
right in c sharp
uh given a
number of let's say we have we're
working with data items right so we can
use link query like this data items dot
skip
so if we are on page one then we skip
zero number of records
and then we take
take how much we take the page size
right
let's let's say each page size is
has 10 items each page has 10 items then
i would say skip 0 take take 10
right and uh if we want to go to the
second page then i would skip
10
right and
take 10.
knowing this
what we can do is we can implement
some of these functionality here
so for example
i want to know how many items to skip
right so i would implement a
function here
i want to know the number of
items
to
skip
and
i need to
provide the current page
number
right
and
if
enabled right so if paging is enabled
then we would apparently it would be the
current page number
minus one
and times the page
size right because for example if it's
we want to go to page one number of
items to skip well let's call it page
number not current page number
it's the page
number that we want to go to
and
let's say we want to go to page one
then
this would be zero so number of items to
return to skip is zero
otherwise it's not enabled
okay then we would return
uh
zero
simply zero right so we're not skipping
any items
so if this is page two
uh we want to go to page two then number
of items to skip is the same of the page
size
right so if it's 10 then we skip the
first 10 items so on and so forth
so the next one uh is
you know number of items that we want to
take
right so i want to implement that two
number of items
to
to take
right um
and again if
you know enabled
but if it's not enabled
number of items to take is basically
the total number of items
so
so
i need to
provide a total items count and we are
returning this total items count
by the way i got a silent keyboard it's
not that silent it's not silent
but i think it's hopefully it's quite
enough and won't be so distracting
um
so if it's enabled
then we're basically returning the page
size
right so if we only have let's say we if
the page size is 10 and we only have two
items in the list
i think by returning
page size 10
uh
and we were executing link query take 10
i think it will not throw an error let's
see
let's see what it does
so we have the number of items to skip
we have number of items to take
next one is that
we basically want to go to a specific
page
page right
so if we know a page then we can just
use these two functions to go to that to
um
to know
along with the link query to go to that
page
um but
what if we just want to go to the
previous page number
or the next page number knowing the
current page number so i'm going to
create those functions first
okay so
um
let's
do the previous page
number
given the current page
number
okay so that's uh that's that's easy i
think if it's enabled
oh well no
if we want to go to the has been enabled
right so
if the current page number is greater
than zero
then obviously we're returning the
current page number sorry greater than
one
then
we're returning current page number
minus one
right otherwise if it's
not then we're just returning the first
page okay so this is the the edge case
scenario
so
we don't want to return minus like
negative number
um the next one
also like the next page also has a edge
case scenario
where when it bridge
when it reaches the
launch pad
the the last page
so for that i want to
pass in the total items called
because i want to i don't want to exceed
that
so that condition um we should say that
if
you know the current page number is
smaller than
the maximum page number
right
well we don't have that let's say let's
just put this here
so that we in our mind is clear so if
it's
if it's smaller than that then yeah we
can just
return the current page number plus one
because we want to go to the next page
if it's
not smaller meaning that we're already
on the last page
then we just simply return the current
page number
right so how do we know the maximum
number a page number it has something to
do with the total items count so i'm
going to create a
i'm actually going to create another
function here
and that
i will call it
max
page number and providing
the
total
number of items
right and here
i'm going to say
um
and you don't know
the total number of pages
obviously right
so that is
um i think it's
yeah so it's number of pages equals
total
total items count divided by
the page size
but these are integers so to receive a
double i want to force a conversion here
and knowing the number of pages
then we just need to do some
so if it's
the same as the floor
number of pages
right then the maximum number of
uh maximum page number so we're
basically returning this
which you can say next page number
so next stage
number equals
the number of pages
and uh it's complaining yeah this is
double so just force it to integer
otherwise
if it if it's
if the number of pages is
it's not a integer then it's
reader so the maximum page number must
be equal to
number
number of pages plus one
right
so
then here i just return the maximum page
number
okay so we have the maximum page number
here
and i can use this
here and pass in the total items count
and
that we will get the next page number
previous page number next page number
and i think we're good now now let's
jump back to the component
what we want to do here is
um
we want to display so we have this
currently it's going through all of them
all of the data items that we have and
it's played all of them and this case
there's no paging
but
if paging is enabled
right
um
because in our page page and config we
actually
use the enabled in these two functions
we're checking whether they're enabled
or not so we can just use that directly
so in here we would say we're looking
through items but it's filtered right we
want to skip
we want to skip
we haven't declared that paging
here yet so let's define that declare
the
paging parameter
which can be passed
through the parent component
basically the developer provide that
information
and that's um
paging convey
class that we have just defined
and
let's call it
and
let's go back and
say
if the paging dot
skip not if
we know that paging and we're skipping
the number of items to skip
number of items to skip
right and it's a function that we need
to provide the current page number
so
um
the current page number
has to be
let's make it a parameter initialize
that to the zero
because you see the print page number
may be used by the developer
yeah so let's let's do that for um
so in the case that the developer i'm
going to provide a custom pager
in that case um that current
page number
needs to be exposed
to the developer
right so and we can
yeah we can we can initialize that to
zero
and current page number is uh
is going to be skipped over here
right and then we want to take
sorry
um
that i think you know it's good and then
we take
and how much we want to take how many
items we want to take
which we can just get from the
so number of items to take which
i need to provide
so this part
um
we have defined and we want to
it takes the total items count number of
items to take
let's think about whether this function
is right or wrong number of items to
take we provide the total
items count and if paging is enabled
then we return
the page size otherwise we return the
whole thing
yeah i think that's right
so
so here we need to provide that total
number of items
right and that's
count
like this okay
so we change this part
and that should render our
data items correctly
now we need to
provide the page we need to yeah we need
to provide that pager
so let me search for uh data great pager
images let's see so it's on the other
one
so
good images i think i want to do a
simple style i don't want to display all
these numbers here i think i want to use
something like this
um
okay
so let's
implement the pager here
again i prefer to use
the beaumont style which we can just use
level
okay so if you haven't used level
you can go to bulma website and we can
use bulma
it's actually pretty simple right so in
order to
i want the page to be on the right hand
side right which is similar to
data grade in
that extreme
and under level i can just say level to
the right
all right and
within it i haven't i need to provide
another one which is level item
and here i can just
define
so here i would say if paging
is provided
and
paging the enable is true
in that case i would render the pager
and this is pretty plain pager
and i want to also be able to
give the developer the option to provide
custom pager
so
i going back to the paging config i want
to add another property here
i want to say bowling and
um
custom
pager
right so if it's a custom pager then
we render the custom pager so
if
paging
dot custom pager
then we render the custom pager
um
which we can provide
a
render fragment here as a parameter
so
which i also covered in one of my
previous episode
if you haven't used render fragment
and this is going to be a simple render
fragment with dot generic type surrender
for recommend custom
pager
so um and it's pretty simple to use
going back over here to say if the
custom pager is enabled
i mean if we want to use custom pager
then just use custom page
that simple and then
otherwise we use our predefined
uh pager here and the predefined pager
for now i just want to use buttons
i wanted to have
yeah we use button for now and then
we'll change to to better style so
button
and
in bulma it's simply called button
um and then um
yeah and this is called previous right
and then we'll have a next
button as well
we just want to make it work for now
and um
obviously when the button is clicked
we want to
go to free
prep page
okay
and again
when it's next button is clicked
we want to go
to
next page
all right so let's implement these two
yeah i think these two should be public
uh because
for custom pager it's just me public
right so go
to
previous page
and then
go
to
next page
and
was
that we can use the paging
functionality to say
you know current page number we
basically reset the current page number
right and then that current page number
can be just used
in here
right and
so that we know how many
how many items to skip
yeah and then we use take to display
so current page number should be equal
to what should be we have that paging
next page
number which we only need to provide the
current page number
right and the total item code is just
data items.com
and what if the data atoms is now do we
have a
columns it's not create a header
reflection the columns is now
what if the columns are no okay so
that's
that wasn't handled properly yet
all right so this has to be handled uh
to see whether otherwise you're gonna
throw exception but i'm gonna assume
that the developer will take the
responsibility to populate the data
items
right so
um data items shouldn't be now let's
consume that
and uh
and if you want to extend my code you
can go to my github
and to extend that
so next page number is this right so
and this one is also
the same paging
dot
wait this is previous so this is wrong
sorry about that
so this is previous
for this page number and i should only
take the current page number
as a parameter
so we have the premiums we have next
what else do we need
we probably don't need anything else
and let's give it a test by providing
the
configuration
um
let's go to the index page and
we need to provide
the page
the paging definition here
and we could just use the line
let's say
that paging configuration here
and
what do we have we have enabled so i
want to enable
right and
what else do we have
here just say
custom pager
false uh page size let's use how many
items did we provide last time
i think it was 10 items
okay so let's say we have three
page size
and we can test the scenario
that the last page should be only have
should only have one item
let's see whether that caused any
problem
so
so yeah so
this should be working let's say let's
see whether it works or not
so i'm going to just run control f5
so that
enables the heart reload
okay so we have the previous next button
unfortunately i want it to be on the
right
but it's on the left
so let's see what went wrong here
um
so going back to the degree component
i have
level level level level level
maybe i need a level left
ready to go
okay so i put a level
i put a level
i'm putting a level left here
and then we go back and refresh the
screen and see
whether that works or not
okay yeah then empty level left
solve the problem and i see three items
right hopefully that's
i'm gonna click on
next page i'm gonna see something magic
happens oh
boy it works
okay
it did work
one
two
so this is on the third page right
because i clicked twice and the last one
should have only one item which is great
so it's working so that take
functionality um
i'm saying take
three but there's only one item left
which is fine right it didn't cause any
problems so we're going back
and i'm clicking uh yeah this is on the
first page so no matter how many times
you click on it it's not gonna go
because we always return zero
uh
yeah number of items through to skip is
always zero
and then we take the
we take three from there
right so let's
let's see if i what happens if we change
that to
two
all right so to two we're gonna have uh
five five pages okay
so
first page it's weird though i can't
click like the first click did not work
and then the second one started working
so this is the second page and then the
third page the fourth page and the fifth
page which is right so it all go all the
way to the first one and then if i click
on the next it's working but then
something is wrong
if i
refresh the page and click on the next
button for the first time it's not
responding and let's check what's
happening
uh yeah let's check what's happening
so i have this
oh so this is index page so i have this
next button
divide handler
and the current page number was set to
be zero
at the beginning
right oh no the current page number
cannot be zero
i'm surprised that
it's skipping correctly
so if i provide zero here what's going
to happen
if it's enabled so if it's enabled
0
oh it's going to return minus
-2
oh so skipping minus two
all right so that's that's something
around there so yeah i think the
initialization is wrong
uh
which i have to fix
in here so the first page number should
be one
and let's go back and refresh the page
and see whether that fix a problem or
not
all right so i'm clicking on next button
that works that's not the problem okay
last last one
first one let's play with some other
numbers here just to make sure all of
the edge cases are covered
so index component
and
what if i use four
uh then i would see three pages the last
page should only have two items right
so click on refresh
all right so four items first page four
items second page two items last page
and that's working
very well for me
okay cool so i need this these buttons
to become i don't like the huge fat
buttons to be here i want to be um a
little bit prettier than that which
i will do
going back to data grid and replace the
buttons with uh
um
actually before doing that i want to
show
which page we are on first right so i
want to have a span here
and then i want to show a number of
pages
page uh current page number
red page
page number of the total number of pages
right so we do have a maximum number of
maximum page number here
again this
problem
happened
so i need to provide
the total
count right so data
items dot
that should be good
takes long time for this to disappear
i don't think i did anything wrong okay
good
all right going back
and we'll see whether that's
better or not
all right so page one well you need some
spacing there
at least it's showing the correct result
okay so we need some spacing
i need some spacing here
and bsp
i
need i'll put two over here and two at
the end
and that should be
pretty good
all right that's good
okay let's replace these uh big buttons
to uh just just expand
and uh
what should we do with this band i want
it to be
bold
and i want to just use
the
yeah just use this
right so for previous just use the less
than less than sign
and then
this would be greater than sine
greater than sine
right and
yeah so both greater than sine
and that should
be
well
i should have just changed the button
but
okay next page
so that's fine
all right so
let's see whether that looks okay or not
okay cool
so we have these um
i think this is wrong
it should be the other way um
so
i think it's
should be this side
and then
any other thing i want to change
i think i want this to be smaller and
then i want to have
a cursor
uh
pointer cursor
right so i'm going to use inline style
font
size yeah i want it to be bigger
let's use 14
and then the cursor
going to be
pointer
right and i'm going to use the same
style
here
and i want these to be smaller size
and definitely not cursor
oops
so i want this to be smaller
and
i want to be not as
prominent as the
buttons so i want to change this to
yeah great
all right
so
let's see what happens okay i like this
look if you have the time you can kind
of disable make this look like disabled
when um
we are currently on the previous
sorry on the first page right and then
make this look like disabled when we're
on the last page which i will not
do
uh
during the video so
yeah so i i think we have done pretty
good job and i just want to perhaps
cover the custom pager
right what if we want to want the
developer to provide a pager so which
have partially implemented this custom
pager here so what if we
go to here and then we enable this
oh sorry it should be true
all right custom painter you go true
and
and we go back
i expect this pager to be gone right
this is pretty fine pager
like we just defined the picture yeah so
that's gone so
the
developer need to come here and provide
that pager
right so
we have that custom pager here
and what should we do here
we should have
maybe we should just use buttons
or
yeah let's use you know let's use some
buttons right and instead of use
so let's let's make it look a little bit
different let's use um
bootstrap
right so btn primary
yeah so you see that blue button which i
don't like but just make them a little
bit different right so how previous next
and uh
and what should we do so the previous
button when we click we need to call
a function like this
oh this is
previous
all right and this is
next page
well
for uh
to make it clear so let's use a
different
function name than the one before
and i'm gonna call it priv prep and next
here
and then
at the
bottom here i'm going to use
a
private function
page
and i'm going to call the great dot
go to next
go to previous page
and then
avoid
next page
great dot
go to next page
okay all right so we have our previous
and next button
let's see whether they work or not click
on next well it's doing its job
right
i like it this thing is top previous one
is not working
previous is not working
oh and there's a typo and it doesn't
even give me an error
that's very weird
all right okay so ctrl f5 again next
previous okay everything works
um
so what if i want to provide that number
of pages per page
uh per page number off page number so
i'm going to go over here and copy this
where is it where is it here
okay
so we have this over here
but what i want to do is instead of
provide this just as a
um
this is a label for
read only i want to
i actually want to implement
a uh
input control here
right
and that's
number
right
and i think there is maximum
and
that maximum number is supposed to be
i don't know whether when i call great
it's going to give you any problems
maximum number
oh it's not returning the maximum number
so
we're going to go back and return that
maximum number
so that's going to be a property
of maximum number
maximum page number
all right and it's going to be read only
and i believe it's going to be
paging that
why
not supposed to be
i just say paging dot
yeah okay so maximum page number do i
need to provide the total what can i do
so data item stop
so going back
and gonna say maximum page number all
right maximum page number is a property
um
and the minimum is
is one
right so
we want to bind this
to
um current page
did we display that i think we did the
current page
number is a parameter
right
i don't know whether we can just do this
parent page number
let's see whether this works or not
so
so we just use this i'm going back and
refresh the screen okay it worked
see i have this input box yeah
so
will it work click on the next very cool
right so f
three
whatever i type four
zero
nothing
twenty five times minus one
the first page great
so i'm now going to demonstrate how to
control these numbers
um
yeah not supposed to go under one if we
use these buttons it's actually doing
that
control but we can actually type in any
number we want
but it's not actually
creating any issues like any exceptions
so yeah we definitely gotta control this
number so it doesn't if we type in eight
the moment you leave this like the uh
the focus the moment the focus leaves
this input box it should revert back to
the
i believe it's three right the maximum
page number
i want to add the sorting functionality
and first thing i want to do is to find
the arrows to indicate
a sorting functionality and on dave
extreme or devexpress the sorting
functionality actually
has
they support both single column and
multiple columns sorting uh i only want
to implement
single column sorting and first i want
to find the arrows so it's gonna be css
arrow
and uh
usually i'm pretty happy with the
w3schools
uh css and i think i like this up and
down arrow so i'm going to
use
this
styles and
so i'm going to go into my css folder
and create a data grade class
style style sheet
and that's going to be
data grade
and in here i'm just going to paste this
here
and uh
so this is the the base one i want to
change to store instead of arrow and i
don't need right i don't need left and
up and down
so that's pretty
good the next thing i want to do is go
to my
component
and i want to
go to my component and find a place to
apply this style
that's going to be my header under my
header which is somewhere
here
yeah it's going to be
somewhere here eh
alright and i think i'm going to add a
span here
right and that's going to be
i'm going to flow to the right
just like
uh
in dive extreme and the class um
i want to call
a method that's called
class sort class and uh i want to
provide the current column
right of course we
don't have this method yet
so let's go here and create one
it's gonna be private method and we're
gonna have store class
and here we're gonna have our column
definition
and our column here and
that's going to be
the logic would be
something related to the star direction
and we haven't created this redirection
configuration yet
right so we have to add a class here and
let's call it sort direction
and it's not going to be a class it's
going to be enumeration and that's going
to have not set
right
ascending and descending
and
that
short direction has to be also added to
the column definition
and from here we're going to say prop
tap tap
and use the sword direction right in
here
and uh call it uh sort
direction
and we initialize that sword direction
to not set short direction dot not
set okay
that's good and then in here we're gonna
have a logic we need to check whether
the sort of direction is
so um story direction is
sad or not set if it's
set already
okay if it's set already then we are
going to
return
because we go to this uh class so we'll
see that how they're the how they are
using it they're using they put the
arrow and then the direction right in
our cloud in our case
uh
we are going to use um
sort because we change it to sort
instead of arrow and then this direction
is going to be
um
column.sworddirection.com to string
and two lower
this is very similar to alignment
we can use that
the enumeration
to string
and if it's
sat already
so
of course here this has to be a string
right and if it's set already then we
return
we return something let's call it no
sword and we are going to add this no
sort thing
in uh you know
cess did it great here and we're going
to say no
short
and because we are using it on a spend
so
in the only thing we want here is to say
display it goes none which we're trying
to hide that span when when there is uh
there's no direction
right so i'm pretty happy with this
going back to the header place
um
this span will need store class yeah so
it's already coded here that's pretty
good and we will actually need this on
all of that
um
um
all of okay so it's gonna be this part
well actually i'm just going to copy
this over
to here and this code should be cleaned
up
i'm just using this
just so that it's
clear what we are trying to do
but
we should use some sort of function to
clean up this uh this whole thing here
so we have our direction
yeah we have our direction and
so we can test this
by initialize our data
so we're going to
go in here and then
let's say i want to
i want to sort with name
okay so sword direction
equals
uh sword direction
sending
and then we're gonna go to our
application refresh the page okay so
it's not being displayed i wonder why so
i'm gonna inspect
okay
so in here
i do have my span
oh i see because i included that css but
i didn't uh
reference it in the whole stop
ch chm cs html so
of course in here i need to include my
new class
which is
i'll use this
obviously i'm going to copy both of this
to be included later then
at the last place
so in here uh it's going to be data
great right
okay
and then we just need to refresh again
i'm going to do a control high five all
right so this doesn't look like it's the
right direction to die
this is a weird direction
um
let's go back to our css and see what
actually happened
so
direction is
oh okay okay so i forgot to change this
because it's gonna be ascending or
descending
okay which
corresponds to our direction
uh in the enumeration
which is uh
where is it
yeah in this enumeration we have
ascending and descending and in our
component
sort class
we are using this to string
so
it's going to be either asc
or
um or not set or desc right so in here
just change that
to corresponds to the enumeration and
then
if i just refresh this again then it's
good
so
we have
uh well data we haven't sorted yet right
but
we have already initialized
our data to be ascending sorry yeah in
here to be ascending
right we have this to be ascending and
then it's showing a up arrow which is
correct except the alignment is a little
bit off and see what we can do to adjust
this
so we have this here
and then so let's see whether we can do
something about so um this is a sending
class in the data great and we want to
do something here
and uh
i wonder whether i can
add some kind of you can
see this using padding
in the sort let's see whether i if i add
some padding here
wouldn't happen
in the ascending place if i add
three pixel
what happened
three pixel of padding
uh didn't do anything right did it do
anything if i change it okay padding
just make it
make the size change
so what if i add some marvin
and
three picks of margin
um
actually okay so it's actually
seemed pretty good so if i use
margin 8
then that would be probably okay
so
let's
go to
my component and then
go here and
so if i do margin
a pixel
that's going to be probably okay and the
next one we're going to test is
to
let's make this descending and see what
happens so for now we're not sorting the
data yet
uh we're dealing with the arrow
the indicator of the sort direction okay
so we also have this problem and we want
to add this uh
as well and
we added margin last time let's see what
happens if we
use three at three pixels if we
i think six is pretty
good
maybe five yeah let's use five
so let's go to our data grade and under
here we would say margin
six
pixel so when you say five okay five
pixel
all right so we're happy with our
direction the indicator of the sword
direction and the next one is we need to
sort our data and to sort our data let's
go back to the data grade component and
in here
whenever we click on the header
we want to
unclick
okay we want to sort data
and uh we also want to provide this
in here and you
need to
to do it to call it uh that way we
uh
yeah it's gonna complain
so we use our
proper syntax here
um
to provide that
and let's define this sword data
function
and
that's going to be
stored data here
and again it's passing in the column
definition
um right
and
column right
and
in here
what we want to do is
because we only support single column
because we only want to support a single
column
sorting
then
first of all
so what is this column this is going to
be the column that you click on right so
it's going to be a sort by column let's
name it meaningfully
and uh
what we are trying to do here is
because you may click on one column and
then you click on some other columns so
first of all we need to clean
clean up the sort direction
of other columns because we only want to
support one sword direction
we only want to support sword direction
on one column so first of all i want to
run through all of the columns
right
and then
if
our column.data field
doesn't equal to
short direction
the sort by column data field if it's
not the same data field
then
we will set this
uh
column
to
store direction.not set right
so then let's reset
any other columns that have a
a star direction already
and then we're going to switch we're
going to see
what direction we are on currently for
this column that we're clicking on
okay so if it's
if it's not set
right so if it's um
if the current column is not set
then
we are going to set it to
async ascending
if the current column is already set um
and if it's already set to
ascending then we want to change it to
descending
right
and
if it's set to as descending already
then we change it to ascending
and if it's default
then that should not since theory happen
but if that happens
we just
set it to
setting again
right so that changes the
uh
i think
typo here to change the direction that
set the correct direction right
and then we're going to look at our
direction that we just set
right so if it's
ascending
then we need to order our data
so
we need to order our data by using the
sort method and that has a
overload
and we just need to
provide the
comparison
uh delegate
and uh
i think
what we should do is to
basically we're just uh
we are um
we can
so at the x is t item right which is our
in this case is our employee
i think
in this case it's our employee right
but it's t items so we have to use
reflection here and then we just need to
get the
uh data of that
of x and then data from the y and then
convert it to string and then we compare
them
all right so we've got to use um
reflection again so we're going to say t
type of t item then we got property
right and then
uh
we get this data field
from the sort direction a sort by column
and then we can get value
get a value
of the x and then we change to stream
right and then
because string has to compare two
so we can then use compare two
compared to what compared to y so it's
going to be the same same thing here
but then we change this to y
right and that's
that's all we want to
do did i close this
this is correctly right
uh let's complain okay so no complaints
good
and then if it's the other way
then
we just copy this
and then
instead of using x here we change this
to y
and then we change this to x
okay that should do
and uh
and then this should be called
in here did we implement that this
should be called in here
providing the column that is being
sorted
and uh also we want to make sure the
same thing is
being called in all of this
column again this
should be cleaned up
but i'm not going to do that here i
think in my github
i have already cleaned up the
markup
so
let's go to
our
code
here
and
close this and refresh
all right so we have our
uh okay we have our header and this used
to be descending
and this definitely wasn't sorted yet
right so we're missing something here so
the initialization is not working
uh
so we
what we should do here is that we should
call our
we should call our sort data
um
method when
we shoot our sort data method when we
are initializing the telegraph component
and that should be
that should that sure let's implement
let's override the unparameter set on
parameter set
and then
oops
and then
in here we need to call these sort data
but which column are we which column are
we i think
we need to modify this method to make
this a
default
as a default value which is now
and then we need to check
if this column is
now
that means we already had a
um sort direction
configured in the initialization in our
case in this case it's the first column
name column
right
so
in this case if it's null then we need
to
find
we need to say sort by column equals
to the columns definition so there's got
to be a
column that already has a
short direction
so i need to find a column that already
had a short direction which means
not that and then if we we cannot sorry
we cannot find it which means if this
redirection
is no
then we're not doing anything
okay
so
do we call it properly double check
so we call it here here here here
here and then here on on parameter site
okay so let's go back and see whether
it works um
everything is sorted but i'm wondering
why it changed to ac
ascending and if i click on it
it does work
but why is it changed to ascending
did we quote it correctly
so if it's
not set
okay if it's a set then we find it when
we find it
we get it
and then we clean up here
and then
if it's not sad
since ascending oh okay okay
okay yeah so this will change it
that's
making the behavior that we're clicking
on the column but
we're not clicking on the column in the
uh
here so we have to say that if sort
direction
if sort column um
so we're going to have a
in here is because
it's called
initial
initial
because
false
issue because um
sort by column
so if it's not in this initial is going
to be true otherwise it's going to be
false so
this has to be false if it's not the
initial method then we're going to
change direction otherwise we're not
changing direction so hopefully this
will fix it
okay
let's refresh all right so yeah this
this looks right okay
this looks right uh let's change this uh
let's add a cursor here right so which
is going to be part of our data grid
class
and that's going to be it doesn't matter
whether it's ascending descending
on it has to be added here so it's going
to be cursor
it's going to be pointer
and then
let's refresh and that should do it
that should do
why it didn't work
did i save it oh okay okay okay we are
this is not the right place
this is the span
um
i think we need to add
here
going to add this cursor thing here
that should do it
okay yeah it's
it's working and then we click on this
okay this is working and i like the
alignment as well
okay
yep sorting works pretty well
okay so now let's see
whether the sorting works with the
paging
i hope i don't need to make any changes
so i need to go over here and then i
need to
really
re-enable the
the paging thing editing is uh
is enabled in
here
okay
and refresh
okay so we have our paging enabled
and looks like the sorting is just
working fine with picking
so j k l
r t
and then uh we test with uh
if we test with the number here that's
also working correctly
all right so
all right cool so we implement our
sorting functionality this is the end of
the course i hope you have learned
something and if you enjoy this kind of
content feel free to come to my youtube
channel at youtube.com franklyu software
thank you so much for watching